who left this den on the table i i would
like to know this it's been here a while
i'm going to say
chris
and who was the last person sitting in
this play point chris right technically
it was me we're blaming it on chris i
don't know
hello and welcome back to trash taste
i'm your host for today gant and once
again with me are the boys
this is technically our first trash
taste recording of 2021 even though oh
you hated it i know right i know
the matter is ruined people the
immersion comes yeah the amount of
options people can tell like i i like
how people are able to tell the timeline
of when trash chase recordings happen
now based on joey's hair
like because it's like one week i was
like oh he has a lot of hair yeah the
next week is like oh he has no hair
it's your hair and my beard because like
one week i just decided i'm gonna grow a
beard and then uh we we are the sundial
of trash
basically
like i'm calculating the the shading
of god's face and i can definitely guess
it sometime around january i like the
beard on here i think it seems yeah it
looks good i think i did it literally
after a trash taste recording when i
went back after that recording where we
talked about beards and i'm like so they
should i grow a beard and cindy's like
just do it why not and uh yeah i kind of
like it now it's grown on me
pun intended
i'm already getting the dashboard i'm
already getting the dad jokes out shave
it off right now
jesus but yeah we've just come back from
our christmas holidays which is i i
think this was one of the first
christmas holidays that actually felt
like a christmas holiday
right because uh normally
christmas holiday is like the busiest
time of the year for me because i'm
trying to get like my end of year video
out and then i don't know what switched
in my mind to make me realize what if i
just don't do that and uh give myself
some time off and then i put the video
out sometime next month god discovers
the word no
for the first time it's like taking a
break yeah i can say that now wait a
minute what you mean the expectations
were just all in my head
and no one really cares if i just delay
the video for like a few weeks never
trust anyone not even yourself
you mean i was my own worst enemy
i feel one i'm just recovering from
being sick so if i'm a little quiet it
doesn't have to cover it don't worry
about it yeah i'm negative boys i'm also
negative in life
you just described yourself right
negative person
what happened like you had like a sore
throat or something yeah i had like a
really bad sore throat and then it just
kind of went and that now i'm in like
the last days where i still sound sick
but i feel totally fine okay yeah uh but
you were sipping that manuka honey up
there though yeah
absolutely
[Music]
yeah that's the problem it's like it's
like i remember i saw the other day it
was like a job this big of manufacturing
like that it was like 60 bucks what is
manuka honey it's it's this plant right
there no it's it's a type of honey made
from a certain i think species of bee
that's only found in new zealand i know
new zealand yeah yeah it's it's a key
it's like a kiwi bee basically and it's
like it's like halfway between i
remember because i saw like a whole
business inside a video on this yeah
it's like uh yeah because they did like
you know
pollinated something like really
specific like this
this is the honey that is spunked on
this i'm sure it's something like the
bee you know takes the pollen from like
a specific plant and only makes honey
out of it or something like that but
yeah it's uh i know it's like a kiwi
thing and the reason is because like
just the whole process of it is really
long yeah and arduous and also it's like
halfway between like royal jelly and
honey i think yeah that's that's how it
kind of works i don't know i don't know
i always recommend it it's really hard
to recommend because people like you're
paying how much for a jar of honey can i
not just buy honey you know that's just
normal honey isn't honey it doesn't do
the same thing no more peasant honeybee
honey
it's like peasant beef
when you when you you know when you pour
honey it pours the like manuka honey
stuff doesn't pull it's like molasses
like a block and like i normally like if
i scream a bunch i'm doing a lot of
voice acting yeah i'll normally just
take a little teaspoon not fill it up
just like a little bit i'll just eat it
yeah yeah i don't know a lot yeah i
don't know why because there are a lot
of like products that are very expensive
and i'd say that they're not that much
different from like the base product
like when you honey versus normal honey
but manuka honey i don't know what it is
i don't know if it is a placebo but it
could be people could be a placebo but
like every time every time i've taken
something it's like my sore throat just
immediately goes away yeah i mean i mean
it's that whole thing of like are you
wearing a product or are you wearing a
brand new thing right when it comes to
like clothes for example yo are these
bees like minted by louis vuitton like
what's going on here if you look really
close on the side of the body it says lv
they're like branded with lv
oh [ __ ] the bees coming in with like the
drip jacket like hello they come to the
farm hello i'm here to pollinate you
uh directions
not from like a specific bee it's from
the manuka flower yeah
yeah
yeah so it's a specific plant they
probably confuse you i said plenty sorry
sorry then joey came in like a wrecking
ball like this and i'm like hold up hold
on pretty sure it's a plus
okay it's the plants wearing there you
[ __ ] drip jacket
should have should have been more
aggressive i don't know joey
i disagree
half this podcast is that doesn't sound
right but my my manuka honey knowledge
isn't enough to dispute you or dispute
you on that yeah people have google
yeah because because i've tried like a
bunch of things like i've tried like you
know that
really expensive pink himalayan salt oh
yeah it's like the most of the cost goes
into
like mining this [ __ ] salt because
it's like one of the rare assault or one
one of the hardest salts to mine durian
they shout out my supermarket huh they
sell at my supermarket do they actually
yeah i've got something it's like
i don't know if it's probably not really
probably it's like two bucks it's
definitely not sea salt with pink dye on
it yeah it's probably sea salt and pink
dye it says himalayan salt on it got it
for like 150 yen yeah
that
i actually tried the second most
expensive i think it's the second most
but it's one of the most expensive
coffee beans in the world yeah right
which is how they harvest this coffee
bean is i believe it it's like this
the cat poop
we've seen the bucket list guys we've
seen the movie we know wait what that's
why i became like really popular because
in the bucket list there was like a hot
this whole big joke in the movie was the
fact that he didn't know this expensive
coffee this rich guy was buying from
poop down which uh which film was this
the bucket list
with morgan freeman and uh jack
nicholson oh
that one okay i don't know i don't know
why i know that maybe i've never seen it
this is why their coffee became so well
known
yeah because in this well it was
obviously it it was a thing before right
right yeah it was a massive part of the
movie it was a big joke that this guy
was like he was like i have to have this
coffee and he didn't know this whole
time that he was eating like cabbage
that was pooping it out yeah
it's not actually cats it's a kind of
like it's like an animal right
a big joke in the movie is that he's
eating the the poop beans and he's like
and then yeah
hilarious
that's why i became so alone that's why
everyone knows it god i'm what i'm more
surprised of the fact that they talk
about that in the bucket list is the
fact that you've seen the bucket list
what do you mean it's a it's an amazing
figure i don't know
i know who's seen it jack dickson and
morgan freeman are you going to sit and
tell me you don't want to watch it it
was it was one of those movies that i
saw
like in my oh i'm [ __ ] dating myself
here i saw my local blockbuster back in
the day oh my god
like you i would say it was one of those
ones that was always on that like
highlighted shelf of like these these
are the talked about movies right now it
was always smack bang in the middle it
was like [ __ ] jack nicholson morgan
freeman don't like that like that kind
of face it just says the bucket list
that looks boring why did not watch the
bucket list i don't know it just never
interested me
i didn't even know about it until now
it's very good so how did they react to
it in the movie he was like shocked
obviously and distraught that he'd been
eating did he enjoy it did he enjoy the
coffee what was it good coffee no so he
didn't he he was obsessed with this
coffee but he didn't know where it was
from all right and because jack nixon in
the movie plays a very wealthy man he
has all the money in the world and
morgan freeman is in the same hospital
room as him and it has no money yeah
it's this whole joke of morgan freeman's
like oh by the way i found out about
those beans that you like so much the
cats poop them out and then it's like
haha
rich man eats poop
that was it was that the tagline for the
movie the original bucket list
it's a very good movie i'm not selling
you on it but it's really good
[Laughter]
oh my god
yeah i mean i i tried it and it was just
uh
sydney gave it to me and sydney was like
making this massive like ceremony about
how it's the biggest [ __ ] deal on
there i've had it before as well and
it's like it's a good cup of coffee it's
a good cup of coffee but it's it is like
to die for no i'll be honest i can tell
when i put it off when i put it on my
bucket list probably i don't know how
much sydney like uh grinded when she
made our cups of coffee because when she
made our cups of coffee it was like i
had three ex like a triple espresso or
something me and team were just like
sitting in our chairs being like
honey i know it's christmas but uh i
think i need to like go out and go for a
run
like i just had so much energy that i
couldn't even think straight oh my god
it's the poop it's the first it's the
poop what is it about poop because i was
i was actually researching this right
not talk about poop of course scott
somehow brought it up trash now it's
trash chase of course you were
researching poop okay yeah i was because
i because after that i was researching
the coffee right and that used to be the
most expensive coffee
in the world
i assume because of the bucket list but
now there's a more expensive coffee uh
which is based on elephant poop and it
comes from thailand and i'm just like
what is it what is up with
what's stopping me from ingesting coffee
beans pooping them out and then just
putting the highest price tag on it
see the sea dog for the eggs
expressway
i've actually seen a japanese youtuber
do that no they actually no way
no way it was it was absolutely
disgusting
i'm not going to describe the video oh
you know you get a sense of the idea why
did he sell it no he didn't sell it he
got afraid to drink it he got his friend
to drink it
yo you're eating you're drinking my [ __ ]
you're drinking my [ __ ] your trash
tastes
taste special i don't know i don't know
how that's on youtube yeah it's
disgusting january's youtube play for
different that reminds me of the story i
saw about the reality tv star that
started selling their farts
did you hear about this yeah and then
she got a heart attack and then she she
farted so much that it gave her like
gastritis or like stomach problems that
she thought she had a heart attack and
had to go and a knee
and so an amazing story yeah so like
and so after that she's just like you
know what i should stop selling farts so
what does she do she starts selling
farts as nfts are you serious i'm i am
deadly serious
this is this is like a month old news by
the time you're watching this yeah it
was very [ __ ] dumb it was so stupid
i'm seeing this and i'm just like you
know what can we go back to black mirror
can we please go back to black mirror
that that that is the future that i want
you know
all these game companies as well being
like nfts we like him and it's like yeah
because you can make money from them
because you can rip us off
yeah so that that yeah i don't know i
just sometimes you just sigh at the
future sometimes wait hold on hold on
back up how do you she's selling her
farts as an nft i i don't know how it
works i don't you know i maybe she's
selling a picture of her farting into a
jar isn't it maybe she farts on the
keyboard
and then like you know there's something
like that
and then like use letter e
you know how like in the movies right
when they're someone's typed in their
their code on the pc
you know you blow the dust [ __ ] on it
you see the fingerprints yeah basically
what happens is that she just farts on
the keyboard and whenever the fart is
like traced on the board she types the
shittiest ouija board yeah maybe she has
maybe she has a fart scanner where it
digitizes her farts into bits and that
gets that gets converted to an nft which
can be put on these
i mean they literally they recently like
japan just made a screen that you could
taste oh yeah the lickable screen yeah
the liquid concepts there so it's all
concept melons like salivating
i never want to lick a screen
it's like half the the good foods
because of the textures yeah what i want
to know is like
this this screen like the screens are
like dirty enough as it is and you're
telling me that there's gonna be people
constantly licking the screen
are you gonna have to like clean it
every time you have like a single have
we not learned anything from this panda
that that is literally the worst idea in
the world
why did you have to announce it now i
bet i bet jojo fans would be happy
like oh my god
right
finally i can leave out my dream
of leaking sweat
jesus christ
oh my god
i just can't get over the [ __ ] fart
it's pretty bad i wonder i wonder i just
want to know how it works now
i don't know i i don't know i i thought
we had can you google this actually for
us can you google can you google fart
nft yeah how how this works please
i thought humanity had hit it slow when
beldelphine uh was selling her bathwater
who knew that that was just the
beginning
that was she was trying to warn us of
the future i think a lot of people sell
their bath water now right
oh my god yeah i mean i'm i'm sure a lot
of people sell bath water now i'm sure
oh yeah i'm sure
no no i'll sell it i'll be honest i i
don't browse only fans so much so
it's so much i mean
you proudest only friends at all
yeah i don't browse only fans so i don't
know
only fans
[Music]
yeah i don't know what people are
selling on only fans i don't know if i
want to know what people are saying on
early fans if this is the kind of [ __ ]
that gets leaked
when i saw the bathwater thing i already
thought that was ridiculous but like
even before that like there was those
places that were selling like you ever
see those like places that were selling
like cans filled with like air
yeah like the oh this is this is a can
filled with hawaiian air and i'm like
really
how did you get that air did you just go
to hawaii you go
like that
yeah just open the jar yeah just open
the shop ship them back i guess ups well
i guess how is that different from
spring water right yeah right
but spring water makes more sense i
cannot understand why someone might make
an argument i don't give a [ __ ] i'll
drink i i i don't give a [ __ ] i'll i'll
put my mouth over the whole tap yeah
you know
get the full lesson
i want the lime scale and all right
but you know i guess some people picky
they you know they don't want it but
normally the whole bottle of water is
just like tap water with they just add
like a bunch of [ __ ] minerals right
yeah there's add [ __ ] yeah i mean do you
mean minerals
i mean elements
i
yeah two shots of lead
i mean it's it's like beauty products
right where the products like they
market
they market the story to you as like oh
we got this we we got this product from
like the the mountains of the himalayas
where like the only like the freshest
tree grows or something like that but
it's just someone in the in the [ __ ]
lab that made it yeah and they put they
stuck a label on it you know it's pretty
much it's no different so you know i i
haven't done enough my research on
where spring where bottled water
actually comes from i don't care
no i don't care
i have no it was the very
noise of nose
i'm like meh i like i will say you have
dismissed that argument any faster
do you care no i just want to know do
you actually care no before we go down
this argument and start talking about
this i don't care it's like guys
i saw like those
those documentaries where it's like
nestle yeah where they just go into like
towns of america and just take all their
drinking water and then just sell it as
bottled water because they add like i
don't know like a label to it they had
like a one
zero milligram of chlorine or something
and then they're like now it's treated
water it's no longer tap water yeah what
wasn't like a massive
controversy um in england at least was
the fact that dasani
um so dasani is still in america if i if
i remember correctly
in america but the reason the sani is
not sold in england anymore is because
there was this massive controversy where
dasani marketed it as you know fresh
spring water but it got found out that
they were just selling bottled tap water
well the tap was coming from a spring or
something anyway yeah but the obviously
the people in the uk are very i don't
know how to explain it stuff like that
really pisses british people off right
the fact that like you would try and
sell us something that is just so basic
it's something
i'm just wondering if if it's spring
water
but it's connected to a tap and that
spring water is coming out of a tap is
it spring water is a tap water it's a
spring tackle [ __ ] sage it's just tapped
sprinkles
we've entered the water metal right okay
i'm gonna bring you a step deeper in the
water metal okay okay so onsen culture
in japan yeah right are you gonna tell
me that every single onsen water is like
is is every single onsen we go to just
you know fresh from the earth or is it
just
like how where does that water come from
it's from the ground but it's through a
tap yeah is it
are you just taking a bath in tap water
like everything no
no
because tap water has to come from
somewhere right
a spring perhaps
i think tap water implies that it's like
the grid the national system
right yeah not not the [ __ ] thing
you're taking offset bathroom guys
because because i see some onsen uh some
onsens have like the water get delivered
to them by trucks right yeah not not tap
water but they get they get it delivered
by trucks and i think well
is it like
i don't know
it's the stuff in the water like the
minerals from like the whatever they dig
out so so there's so there's a clear
difference between an onsen and a
centaur which is a bath house
right acentor is just hot water it's no
there's no minerals in it it's not it
doesn't have like any of like that you
know natural stuff that makes you you
know makes it healthier yeah yeah and
then an onsen is the stuff that is like
mineralized like from the [ __ ] ground
like onsen water yeah right but i think
most people just assume that like oh
bath house equals onsen which it doesn't
yeah yeah it's two different things yeah
because like i i do notice depending on
the onsen we go to like the the
water is like very different depending
on where you go oh yeah there's like
there's like 30 different types of
ridiculous yeah yeah it's probably yeah
so yeah because it's all just different
makeups right yeah like like the acid
one i went i went with chris into an
acid onsen
and then
the one we
that we just went on holiday yeah on a
ski trip which uh we've revealed is not
going to be a special yeah unfortunately
we do like to hang out with each other
and uh not always happen
we hang out outside of context outside
even though joey joey
which may or may not not be out by now
by now yeah but uh we went to
uh where did we go again you said koi
it's okay no coins that's a that's a
monster that's a manga i i completely
just i the
second
musical that's that's it
one of the most famous ski resorts in
japan probably like top two is the most
famous oh hakama and niska the two
famous ones oh yeah that's true they're
two big boys
that's not that famous though yeah it's
always famous in japan i've also been
there and is like very very old yeah
it's it's it's not as great every ski
lift is like a plank
it just like took yeah i mean hand crank
i mean i would say that this is my first
proper ski trip because unlike before i
only went for a day
and then i was like out of commission
for like every other day so i had like
one day of snowboarding this time i had
basically
like four days of snowboarding two like
full hard days and two like kind of like
softer take it easy days still four days
of snowboarding and uh yeah it was a lot
of [ __ ] fun yeah but my god did my
body hurt the day after holy [ __ ] did
your mum ask you how the white person
sport was
so she asked you
[Music]
it was so weird going to that ski resort
and just going to that town and just
seeing more people speaking english then
they were japanese i think i heard less
japanese like i heard more chinese and
english than i did japanese oh yeah
and that's only going to increase once
the board is open yeah yeah yeah because
like every single staff member not just
in the hotel we stayed at but just in
town for some reason
that spoke english and you know there
are a lot of a lot of aussies there a
lot of water
um and you know if they weren't speaking
english then they were basically
speaking you know
mandarin or cantonese
and then you had the very few people
just speaking japanese the japanese
people were literally in the minority
yeah from what i could see and the
country's closed off so how bad is it
going to be when
the country actually opens up and
tourism comes back in because yeah
because i remember because i remember
when i worked in uh hakuba which is the
other famous one nigata that is like
it's like almost 99 percent are you
being sorry i'm sorry nagano yes sorry
uh it's like 99
australians
like it's actually it's actually scary
like i remember some days being there
like going around to like restaurants
and stuff yeah and i would step outside
after the restaurant and i'd be like oh
yeah i'm in japan
because when you're inside the
restaurant everyone's australian yeah so
it feels like i'm back home in australia
it feels like every country has their
their national pests yeah
australia has the cane toads yeah that's
australian australians
localized resort
she's going and you're like oh yes it
can't yet
so you know when you're at home
oh my god no because yeah it was it was
super surreal for me being in a place
which was you know very clearly japan
but you know all the signs were in
english the menus were in english um and
all the staff members spoke english as
well weird man it was weird like i tried
my best to speak japanese to like anyone
i met you know whenever i went to a
cashier or something and anytime i did
they would just always reply back in
perfect english
that's funny because when i was booking
the
hotel actually i picked the hotel for
results
but i booked it right i asked like for
like a shuttle service to pick us up
because it's like two hours two hours
and a half yeah from the airport yeah
and i was like well there's you know on
booking.com it says they have a shuttle
service oh great great so i clicked it
two days before they uh they messaged me
they're like by the way we don't have a
shuttle service and i was like
what
what do you mean you know shuttle
service they're like i have one but we
can help you get one just go to these
links and get the bus yeah and so i go
and look for the bus there's no seats
left on the bus i'm like oh [ __ ] what'd
we do yeah i call up the hotel and then
i remember so this is where i i talked
to the guy and i'm like i'm like oh is
english okay in japanese and he's like
in english he goes oh thank god
yeah that's great that's perfect
i was like yeah i don't really like
speaking japanese
he's like from the philippines
okay i was like all right i'm sick and
he was like super chill he was like yeah
yeah we'll get you a taxi mate you'll be
all right yeah
very expensive taxi oh my god
[ __ ] up we didn't book beforehand like
normal people because we we booked the
trip pretty late as well right we're
like two weeks before yeah yeah so it
was like quite expensive but it was good
though but like it's like a smack bang
in the middle of the season as well so
it's probably like the most amount of
people but it was really good yeah still
very good i would say this was like
probably the coldest weather i've
consistently been in because like
throughout my entire life like the
coldest weather i've really had to deal
with is like minus five minus six right
oh god okay so how did you manage huh
how did you manage so so like so like in
my mind when you guys were telling me to
pack winter clothes pack all these
different kind of like you know
thermal gear and everything like that
i'm just like it's cold i get it i know
i'm going to i know it's going to be
cold
nothing in my mind could process really
just how cold it is up there and just
how cold it feels because to me
like it gets to -5 and anything below -5
i'm just like [ __ ] it's cold i'm
like
i know mother it is cold you know that's
how my mind processes it yeah but i
didn't like my body wasn't prepared for
just like the different types of
coldness because it just never had
experienced that before at least like
not too not to such a big degree because
i've been in you know wisconsin in
winter and it gets [ __ ] cold in in
there but we just stay inside all the
time we're not out there [ __ ]
snowboarding skiing yeah yeah
yeah to put in perspective i think every
day on average it was like minus like 10
or 11. it was yeah it was minus like 16
at the top as well yeah yeah yeah it
wasn't
like shot down even lower yeah like
because you'd wear like this um i don't
know what you call it not a battle club
but like just like a cloth
like a like a face
mask well it's just like a piece of
cloth that you put underneath your mask
that blocks here so you don't freeze
your face off yeah but like the one of
the days was so cold that like after
like one run of going down like one of
the things i tried to touch it and it
was rock solid yeah like it like really
moved it's just like frozen yeah it's
crazy it was so cool though man it was
such a such a cool ski resort it was uh
i guess being in that kind of cold
weather or being that in that kind of
cold place kind of put things into
perspective for me
with that if you are like ill-equipped
like just to go outside for like a quick
walk or something you'll probably die
yeah
and i guess i've never been in an
environment where i've needed to
worry about just having basic gear to
protect myself from the weather
otherwise my life would be in danger you
know what i mean yeah and i yeah like it
gets cold but it's like bearable yeah it
gets cold but like just runs in there
it's combing in it just once in there as
tesco's and just warm up you you run a
bit more but like um the nearest comedy
was like 30 minutes yeah yeah yeah
because there's not there was nothing
right and i remember when we arrived
when we arrived to the hotel we got
greeted by the receptionist and
everything like that and he said oh you
know um if you want to go into town
make sure you book a taxi because if you
don't book a taxi every taxi is going to
stop at about midnight
and they've had some people that have
gone into town which is a bit further
away from the ski resorts and had no way
to get back in like minus -10 weather
it's like a 20-minute drive it's like a
20-minute drive yeah it's like it's like
a two-hour walk yeah yeah yeah yeah
because the ski resort has a bunch of uh
different areas around it yeah
yeah we we went to this village called
hirafu which is technically on the next
mountain over that just puts into
perspective how far away that is yeah so
it just made me think [ __ ] man if if we
just forgot to call a taxi one day we'd
just be [ __ ] because nowhere would be
open we can be we can we can get home
and we just have to like survive outside
in the wilderness and like minus 10
minus
10 degree weather celsius by the way
celsius we went to that one bar and was
these australian or south african i
think it was australian uh no no no he
was dutch i believe was he really oh i
think his eyes wasn't he touched him his
accent sounded like he's already had a
nausea this guy was just like he was
just like we're like what do we do if we
miss the cabs i wouldn't know if he was
also
okay so okay he definitely wasn't aussie
he was he was he was european we asked
him we're like what do we do if we miss
the cabs and the guy's like oh just walk
home no no
he said no he was like where are you
staying and i was like uh at the xyz
hotel he's like it's walkable
and i looked at the google maps it was
like an hour and 40 minutes an hour and
40 minutes i'm like
it's certainly walkable
would i do it though
in minus 15 degree weather is a
different question
i mean walkable is a technicality i can
yeah i'm sure a human would be able to
walk from one end to the other i mean
hokkaido to tokyo is walkable
like you can walk it if you would want
to i mean the south pole is walkable
people have done it if you're jesus you
can walk anywhere
this episode is sponsored by princess
connect jesus christ you've already
taken one life this year on the cooking
special calm down
remember when you two stuffed your
mouths full with onigiri last year let
me remind you both that this episode is
sponsored by princess connect and
today's the one year anniversary of
princess connecticut and to celebrate
we're going to be reliving that good old
dead meme of 2020. eating more onigiri
no
because this
is actually cake
no way
i don't know why i cut it you can easily
just eat it that's it i might if i do
what flavor have you got oh the turmeric
fruit nice chocolate chocolate i got
cookies and cream well while the boys
are pleasantly eating the cake this time
let me tell you about the free stuff our
sponsors at crunchyroll games are giving
out to all of you anime fans out there
you get free 10 draws every day i repeat
every day free 10 draws until february
the 15th of the game and double rate ups
on all three star characters when
pulling on the new featured banner oh
that's sweeter than this cake i'm eating
right now joey the new banner features
mimi and the princess gala plus a bunch
of other characters you don't want to
miss out on if you've never tried
princess connect this is the best time
to check it out and join over five
million others in on the action links in
the description below yo hand me some of
that cake yeah i might try and try
unfortunately you don't get these
delicious onigiri cakes but you might
get your favorite princess connect waifu
thank you to princess kenny for
sponsoring this episode back to the show
this is so nice though it's so good we
had like like a really nice onsen in the
hotel like yeah it was one of the best
launchers i've been in being cold all
day and then just going in the onsen and
the ensembles outside as well yeah so
good so you get this but like if you
kind of put yourself in the water maybe
up to like your chest or like the bottom
of your shoulders you get this perfect
blend of like your bottom half is nice
and warm and toasty in this mineral
water and then your top is just getting
colorful
it's so anime it's it's so anime
especially like having in going in an
onsen is anime going in an onsen in snow
is just like this
it's pretty animated because you you're
literally sitting there and you you see
the anime steam where the way you know
you see the steam when it like senses
everything that's literally what it was
like you couldn't see anything like
there's just so much steam yeah yeah you
couldn't see anything it was amazing
yeah so it's just like a real life
sensor and so this view we had of just
the snow as well it looked
so [ __ ] aesthetic it was just unfair
it looked like a wallpaper it was like
unreal engine fire
it literally looked like an unreal
engine
of not real life
it looks so good that it looks
unrealistic
that's the only part i regret not being
able to vlog because that was probably
like the most aesthetic part i can't
take a camera in there i can't take it
what's going on guys yeah [ __ ] dicks
out boys
[Music]
yeah because it was it was so cold on
top that as you were like as you were
just staring at the landscape your hair
would freeze yeah so like our hair was
frozen solid while our bottom halves
were like nice nice and toasty it was so
weird because like even though your hair
is frozen and like your shoulders and
head are just like covered in snow
you're not cold because you're sitting
in boiling hot water yeah you're sitting
in boiling water so it's like this
perfect weird balance and it's just yeah
so
i don't know what minerals they had
going on in that bath but like every day
i felt like silky smooth
i felt amazing it was boring
like
sometimes a bit of bath water just slips
in god i sound like [ __ ]
i sound like [ __ ] mail-in now
you
sometimes like my face was like freezing
cold i needed to like warm it up
that's what the towel was for god
oh you got that you got the you get the
water on the towel as well you know
that's true how was your skiing a
snowboarding gun it was uh
you improved a lot i did think i
improved i think gone improved
definitely like i definitely my
confidence went way up from like day one
to day four having said that i think i
learned the most on day four
right because
day one two and three i had one goal
survive right and uh
the [ __ ] halo music starts
an objective survive because like
because
you go you go down some of these slopes
and i was having a chat with connor
about you know there are like green
slopes there are like red slopes and
there are like black slopes but at the
end of the day it's just a [ __ ] label
you know god's not god's not there
creating mountains being like i'm going
to make this a green slope at exactly
these the same angles throughout i'm
just like and the map is like yes
he's just like playing like sim city
with the [ __ ] earth or whatever you
know god's not [ __ ] doing that you
you're you you get what you're given
with the mountains not every mountain
and not every slope even if it's labeled
a green slope there are different
variations there are different variables
some of the red slopes are actually
easier than the greens i would say so i
would say so yeah so if you're not
familiar with uh snow sports at all uh
the slopes normally categorized in
colors or
diamonds wherever you're from shapes
yeah yeah normally it's uh green is
easiest then some some also use blue in
europe australia so in europe you
sometimes see green you sometimes don't
it depends on which country you're in
but it's normally blue red black and in
america you have black diamond japan
also uses black diamond as well yeah
it's red circle uh sorry green circle
red square black diamond yeah yeah oh
wow yeah because in japan there's
squares like green circle green circle
because normally the the biggest
variation of difficulty comes in black
slopes yeah because they're like some of
them are literally just like they're not
treated at all yeah some of them are
just awful and so that's why there's
even uh normally a bigger scale but in
europe it's just all black yeah they're
like [ __ ] it it's all so hard yeah so
you've been skiing before yeah so on the
first day we just stayed on like
literally the baby beginner slope it was
literally like i did
me and god did because it was like the
warm-up slope yeah me joey and luke
stayed on the beginner slope the baby
park slope of this [ __ ] ski resort um
and then the next day we're like okay
we're feeling confident now
actually take the gondola up to like the
top of the mountain and ski down the
green slopes um so
there was like no distinction from me
from what was a green slope and what was
a red slope we actually followed connor
and we accidentally took a red slope i
didn't i couldn't tell the difference
exactly because they were that was just
like me [ __ ] fighting for my life to
go down like the tiniest little slope
and that's that's like i couldn't tell
the difference between like a few
degrees not to mention the weather that
day was so [ __ ] like the visibility was
like five meters yeah yeah so the so
this uh this resort had a beginner slope
and i when i said beginner slope this is
the most beginner slope i've ever seen
yeah it is literally like a flat surface
that sometimes it goes to a one percent
yeah it's like a one or two so you know
really
amazing if you're actually like
beginners beginners which luke was yeah
like yeah yeah yeah yeah with a friend
who came with us luke who had never
skied in his life yeah and it was a good
start i mean i think he got confident on
that yeah yeah he did he's like oh i've
only fallen over once i can go to the so
if you wanted to go and do any other
slopes that were kind of difficult we
had to go all the way to the top yeah
and that's where it kind of gets you
don't really have a choice if some of
them are difficult or not yeah yeah but
the day before we went up
we went up the day before and it was
like the visibility was awful yeah like
you could maybe see like five meters
ahead of you yeah and we go pretty fast
and it's like just like i'm just hoping
i don't find someone because if i do i'm
gonna hit someone and it's like oh god
oh god it was really sketchy really bad
and then but even the second day the
visible is quite [ __ ] right yeah yeah so
the first day was a lot worse i
literally couldn't like maybe i couldn't
see what that camera oh wow maybe no no
maybe ashley where ashley is that was
about where it starts to get blurry and
i couldn't see anything right right yeah
but the next day was it was still bad
yeah but it was bad so so we went with
another friend uh ohara he's a youtuber
uh who lives here and then we were he's
chris as well yeah and chris
as well all right so to give you to give
you a gauge of like the skill levels i
guess like what would you put yourself
what would you put yourself i would say
it's it's
yeah yeah so so like
uh i've like no issue doing like black
slopes or whatever so me and ohara
because we were like the most confident
ones you're like alright i was like you
go in the front you like direct them and
i'll go in the back and i'll like if
they fall over i'll help you but i'll
help them get back out
luckily i'm glad i was there because
luke at one point lost his ski in like
really thick snow
and when you're in ski boots you can't
really go up the mountain if you're not
used to it like if you're if you're like
a beginner it's really hard to like feel
confident running around
and i was wearing snowboard boots so i
was like all right just wait there i'll
go and dig through the snare and after
like five minutes i've managed to find
this [ __ ] ski buried in the snow it
had gone underneath the snow slid so you
couldn't even there was no sign yeah
yeah oh [ __ ] it was there so i just had
to like rummage through yeah eventually
found it so we went down anyway but like
so we took these guys up and it was just
a mess because like none of them could
like stand up chris is good at skiing
but chris is lazy right
i did notice that i didn't know chris
chris ken and eric and chris could
probably do a black slope right yeah
yeah maybe yeah if chris really tried
yeah problem is black slopes are really
tiring and take a lot of effort yeah
chris doesn't want to do that and chris
also is like he'll do reds but you
really have to convince him he's trying
to do greens he's like chris you could
do reds so easily what are you doing
yeah because i remember like the third
or fourth day he came with me gotten
luke on a green slope because that's
when we started to get a little more
confident and he was like yeah i think
i'll stick on the green too and i'm like
[ __ ] off almost get out of here you
passed the exam
he's like [ __ ] skiing past us with no
problem whatsoever come on boys catch
second day we tried to take them down
and uh yeah how long did it take us to
get to them okay so
if if i went from top to bottom without
stopping and i went as fast as i could i
could probably do it in five minutes
right yeah but that's like dangerously
it probably took us
30 to 45 minutes no it took us like an
hour
it took like two hours the first time at
least the first time because
like we i swear we spent like 15 to 20
minutes looking for what you were
looking for uh luke's skis and then uh
before that as well because this was
right at the start so the visibility was
so poor
i probably would have a hard time seeing
joey from where from where he's sitting
that's how poor the visibility was um
and this was also like basically my only
like my second full day skiing uh so
it's snowboarding so
um i didn't know how to properly control
my board
and i remember we were trying to stick
close to a group right we're trying to
stay close to a group and i'm trying
like i'm fighting for my life just like
see where the group was right and so we
and so before every hill we all stop
before hill um unfortunately my control
of the board was not good enough that i
knew how to stop yet
so so these guys were stopped waiting
for me and luke and um so i come along
and i try to stop and i realize that i'm
stopping too late and i'm sliding down
the slope so i start shouting out oh
guys i i'm going now i'm just gonna go
ahead and like and and nobody looked
nobody looked nobody looked back and i
just started stumbling down this [ __ ]
hill get halfway down and i turn around
to see if anyone's followed wait a
minute
wait two minutes wait five minutes
there's nobody and i'm just like
[ __ ] where is everybody
i am on this slope at the top of this
mountain by myself and i can't even
[ __ ] stop correctly so i had to like
i was like messaging the lion group
trying to get their attention luckily um
luckily i waited long enough for you
guys to come down because they these
guys were waiting for me this entire
yeah i thought that garm was behind us
yeah yeah
that's how poor the visibility was um so
yeah we wasted just 20 minutes where you
were waiting for me and i was waiting
for you
just because we couldn't [ __ ] see
each other because i was very worried
because this uh the way that this
mountain was laid out is that like
basically you have to do like
really big s's to stay on the easy ones
and if they take if they took any turn
at any point they would go down a black
slope yeah it's just a cliff and i was
like uh they're gonna die if they go
down a black slope yeah so i was like i
got to do my best to make sure like we
got i'm like like uh what are they what
are the [ __ ] sheep dogs like
trying to round them around up all the
sheep
come on boys stick together yeah
yeah it was kind of like that uh which
is why i think i learned the most on the
last day because uh on the last day we
just found like this one slope that was
perfect for beginners and had like a ski
lift take us back up and you just had
like the freedom to just do what you
want without worrying about
dying or just you know breaking
the weather was absolutely good and the
weather was like yeah so we had three
days of god-awful weather really bad
weather and finally the last day when
we're leaving it's amazing and it's a
shame really because the next few days
after that was also really good yeah so
we kind of booked it the wrong time but
it was amazing weather really good stuff
in the last day i'm really impressed
that nobody got injured like yeah yeah
because i agree yeah there's six of us i
mean did you guys take any bad tumbles
during uh yeah
i let's just say i'm really glad i
rented out a helmet because uh
i think about 80 of my falls involved me
just my head just getting [ __ ]
whiplash back right didn't you like kill
a toddler
i almost did i i
i because like like on the first like
two three days i didn't know how to stop
so my technique for stopping uh involved
falling over um and if i didn't fall
over i would just basically just take
out whoever like was in front of me this
is this great photo that luke took of
you just like there's this kid right
here and then there's just gone
menacingly behind me like i'm about to
destroy
i must have decked at least like three
kids on the slope for like the first
three days oh my god god
the kid killer thank god no one got
injured except for those three
like it was because it was like a
competition because like
me and luke just kept [ __ ] crashing
into each other in the first two days
because we had zero control yeah we
didn't know how to control our balls
right and i remember uh luke decked joey
yeah [ __ ] legs sweeped me i had a
great pov of this i was like really i
was i was my i was like leading everyone
down the right slopes
and then i was waiting for them at the
bottom and i saw joey just
slowly like going down like this
yeah and then out of nowhere like rko i
just see our friend luke who doesn't
know how to stop she's coming coming and
i see jerry
and i'm like i'm about getting my
popcorn out
just waiting for this to happen so yeah
joey's going joey's going doesn't move
his head at all and then suddenly he
just goes doom
right in the back of his legs and joey
just flips over like i'm so funny
because all i heard was i was i was i
was slowly going down because it was
kind of a narrow stretch and also i was
waiting for luke right yeah so i was
slightly going down because i saw you
guys there and i i remember specifically
behind me i could hear luke in the
distance going sorry sorry sorry sorry
this is getting louder and louder and
louder but i thought he was saying that
to other people right that were behind
me yeah so i was like well luke you know
silly hear me silly him it gets louder
sorry sorry sorry and then just bam
right in the back of my knees
let's get flipped over
i should have been more concerned but it
was so funny i wish you had filmed that
yeah
by the time i realized it was happening
was like five seconds
couldn't have got my phone out but i
wish i did i wanted to see i wanted to
shut up we should have my gopro on
permanent yeah right i was too busy like
falling over myself to really see what
everyone else was like falling over over
because i remember i had a few bad
tumbles but actually like some of the
worst tumbles was when i was just
actually not going the fastest it was
like because when you go fast sometimes
like you saw you guys saw me do have
some pretty big fours where i did like a
[ __ ] triple backflip or whatever yeah
or whatever but to me those falls are
fine because you take the momentum and
then you just like literally roll with
it right and you hardly feel it some of
the worst falls i had was on like the
second day because he saw this one yeah
these guys were trying to like warn me
not to stop myself with my hands right
because sometimes if you have a bad four
and you stop yourself with your hands
you uh you could break your wrist you
could snap your wrist or break your arm
or something so they were telling me uh
you've got to you've got to fall on your
arms you've got to do this make sure
make sure you don't try to catch
yourself you've got to do this i need
like like this right and i took that as
i'm going to do this
[Music]
not realizing the mistake i was about uh
to encounter because what happened is i
had a like i was taking a bunch of
tumbles i was like this doesn't hurt i'm
i'm a [ __ ] pro at falling over with a
with a snowboard so there's one time i
was going down this really like this
this this if the slope wasn't steep at
all it's going pretty slowly but i just
catch the edge and i'm about to fall
straight to my face so i do what they
tell me and i tuck my arms in
unfortunately my fists were right in
front of my face right so what happens
is i fall on my arm and i just [ __ ]
deck myself in the face
i just go
and i remember
i fall over and you know
like you know when you have a bad four
and you just gotta like lay there yeah
just question life for a bit that's when
you know it's bad yeah yeah and i
remember i lay there for a few seconds
and i just hear kind of going right on
because i just saw this like because
obviously it looks like ants in the
background i just saw he can't just fall
on his face and i was like get back up
come on
get back
get back up and then he didn't get up
and i'm like oh no he hurt himself
that was like it was a couple of times
like like on the last day i think where
you did that like triple back flip right
oh yeah i saw it in the distance and i
was like oh that that that looked like
it hurt and then god just did a move for
about 20 seconds i was like oh he's dead
oh he's straight up dead
yeah i never seen that one i just saw
like someone doing like flips but not
good i could hear the ssx music playing
when that was happening
he took so many falls i did i did
i think that's when i learned the most
though when you when you do take the
falls it's not about how many times you
get hit down it's how you get how many
times you get back
yeah that's about the drive it's
actually like the most embarrassing fall
i took wasn't even on the slopes it was
on the ski lift
oh yeah uh yeah because uh well joey was
there because uh me and joey were trying
to get on the ski lift together for two
minutes so two it was a yeah it was a
two-man ski lift so me and joey line up
together so we're just gonna have a nice
chill ride up on the mountain and so i
look back i've done the skeeter for a
bunch of times so i'm not even a
beginner anymore i'm like
i i like know how to get on the ski lift
right so so you think it is
it is a lot harder on a snowboard than a
ski yeah also i thought because i just
so i'm standing there waiting for the
ski lift to come around i look back
and in my mind i take a mental note of
the momentum
of this ski lift right so i know how
fast this thing's going yeah and so
right before
uh it gets to uh it gets near us i turn
around thinking it's gonna have the same
momentum not thinking that they're gonna
slow down slow it down for us
so what i do is i turn around and i just
sit
and you know that feeling where you take
a step where you think there's like a
stare yeah and then there's just not
so i just
i had that i had that feeling where i
sit down
and i just feel nothing and i'm like oh
no and like i just i just collapsed yeah
yeah and then the next thing i notice is
i feel like the [ __ ] bump on the back
of my helmet which thank god i was
wearing a helmet at this point yeah and
so i'm just like they're gonna stop the
ski lift so my instinct uh is just to
adopt the fetal position well while they
hopefully stop the ski lift
plot twist they don't stop the ski lift
and so the ski lift just goes over me
and joey just like joey i guess just
snowboards over me because i look at
yeah i look up thinking what the [ __ ]
happening and i just see joey just
looking back on the skeely being right
you're right [ __ ]
it was because it was amazing because
like i'm surprised they didn't stop it
they said yeah they should stop right
because like because how i usually do it
with like skis or snowboards is i wait
for the the chair to physically hit me
in the back of the knees so that's where
i know oh it's right underneath kind of
like bend over yeah just get my butt
ready so i was i was doing that i was
looking back you know just waiting
waiting waiting waiting until it hits me
right here and then i look over look up
sit down thinking it's all good and then
i i hear like this horrible scraping
sound from somewhere i was like what's
what's going on i look over and god's
just down there
under the thing just like this
and i was like oh they're gonna stop it
they don't stop it it's right over gun i
was like all right that's cruel
and then they finally stop it after
it's it's gone past you yeah yeah and
the woman comes over being like you're
alright i'm like what do you mean you're
all right yeah you should have stopped
why did you why did you check up on him
after you left the chair
it's like it's like watching a fight
with the teachers like watching the kids
like when it's over like oh you guys
you're sorry i was like i'll wait for
them to throw a few yeah i'll break it
up break it up let's bring it over here
well that was the most embarrassing one
because they're just like everyone was
just obviously staring at me i stopped
the entire ski lift and yeah that was
just just like social anxiety up through
the roof because i'm just like it
happens yeah i know it happens they
can't see your face yeah that's true
that's true you're completely coughed up
yeah aside from that had a [ __ ]
wonderful time uh my body hurt a lot but
yeah it was worth it
i'm i'm like just wearing i'm raring to
go again honestly it's probably some of
the best snow i've ever snowboarded or
skied on my life this is amazing how is
it compared to like european ski resorts
um i think i like european ones more
there's normally they're normally bigger
way more like options but i mean it was
the quality of snow was insane it was so
good powder it's it powdered snowed like
so like two meters a day or something
yeah yeah so most of the black slopes
weren't like groomed so we went on one
and it was literally just like i was
like on a cloud yeah yeah and i fell
over on one of them because it's too
deep and it's so hard to turn and it was
really bad because i basically just
shoveled a [ __ ] ton of snow into my
jacket and pants
and i was freezing and i was like in the
cold of my my hand trying to scoop this
out
minus 15 trying to get all the snare
because if you just leave it in it'll
just melt and then you'll be wet yeah it
doesn't even worse
try to get it out like [ __ ] [ __ ] and
then i had to like ski for another hour
my my ass was completely numb
i couldn't feel anything it was so bad
and i i when i got back to the room i
was like i can't i can't feel my ass at
all it's been numb for like a good two
hours
someone could have smacked my ass and i
wouldn't know that clip is definitely
going to be taken out
i can't kill my mouth i just took such a
beating it's so numb
doing too much riding on the board
it's so good though it was really cool
there's really good ski resorts i want
to
go
pain in the ash to get to but good
yeah i think if i if i go there again
i'd probably want to like go to sapporo
for a bit or something yeah and then go
there i think i think that's what like a
lot of uh tourists do is they're like
kind of maybe dedicate like a week or
two for like the whole thing because it
is kind of out of the way especially if
you're coming from tokyo is a really fun
city yeah as far as grace is a really
chill city like all i wanted to do on
this ski trip was just get the basics
down for my snowboarding and i think i
managed to do that
yeah so now i'm like more confident
thank you came along very well
improved a lot but uh yeah now i'm just
ready to like tear it down with the boys
for real hopefully and try and try and
keep up with them the real ssx trickies
i want everyone to get better so that
then chris feels obliged
but he has no choice because no one
wants to do greens anymore yeah i mean
we accidentally went down a reds on our
second day like like we just said it
didn't go amazing but we made it down
didn't go amazing uh but we survived
that's the important thing we have yeah
there was like there was this um there's
basically there was this tiny little and
little little sign that was like go this
way if you want to go back to where you
came from on a green yeah and if you go
down straight which is like the whole
thing you know you wouldn't it's really
hard to see this thing because it also
goes back in on itself yeah so the slope
goes down this way and there's a little
cut off here where it goes down and back
around and then joins off to like
another mountain it's impossible to see
considering and the entire thing is
white
the conditions are really bad so it's
just everything explains and then i was
last because i was making sure everyone
was all right and then i i was like oh
no the
luke who i was with at the time because
i'm pretty sure he was last he went down
the red and i was like oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
moments before a disaster he just went
down
and then i'm like oh my god they've all
gone down the green and then we're stuck
here and it's like lunch time yeah yeah
and we was already it was like 1 1 30
and i was like oh we probably would be
eating by now like we're [ __ ] because
we want to go meet have lunch with them
as well so how do we get back like but
then luckily all these [ __ ] idiots
went down the red as well turns out we
all missed it
so we all met up yeah yeah but then this
green was really annoying as well
because it was like you had it was like
a flat really really flat and i told the
guy i was like guys you got to make sure
you get as much speed as you can on your
snowboards yeah like walk anywhere we're
like got it put snowboards on two
seconds later falls on our ass all right
taking it off walking the whole way yeah
so i'm going as fast as i can as i can
i'm like getting low to the ground like
get out of aerodynamics i get i get over
there and i'm like oh my god i made it
all right nice i'm waiting i'm like
they'll come any second now like 10 10
minutes later they come around the
corner walking
and i was like what is this
okay to be fair we did
we did attempt to snowboard to to me it
wasn't a case of getting to the end to
me it was a case of how far can i get
before i fall over because like i knew
once i fought i fell over that was it
momentum was going i gotta take off my
[ __ ] it is hard to
uh go fast on a snowball much easier on
skis um i don't know i i just kind of
again i like i was like i'm i'm all
self-taught with it yeah so i just you
just kind of get a feeling for it oh
yeah sure yeah by the end of the week we
all i think definitely got a feeling for
it go fast go fast i mean we were going
a hell of a lot faster on the last day
compared to the first day that's true
like god was [ __ ] blitzing down this
mountain and i was like oh god he's
about to ssx tricky right now i could i
could feel it
yeah well we had to get back to like our
ski resort
and
the they closed their like way of
getting over yeah yeah what would you
call the what's the another brilliant
thing what's the it's like a pathway
what's there's a word for this right
well pathway no no slalom
there's a i've got the word i forgot
what it was there's a word for like an
entrance
that is like a i don't know
an entryway
you're literally using all the words i
know i know so there's a path right and
it closes at like 3 30. so we had so i i
was like [ __ ] okay if you don't go back
over as well you have to get like a 30
40 minute bus ride yeah yeah and i'd i'd
rather kill myself than your bus
it's just so depressing when you've got
your ski gear yeah yeah you've got to
sit on this bus and it's like oh no i
why would i do that when i can ski back
right yeah i'm not so i me and ohara
were going to go back over and then we
asked the guys we're like are you guys
coming and they're like ah no we'll get
the bus because it was like kind of
tough we had to ski a bunch
quickly get on a chair lift ski over
then walk over and then ski back down it
is kind of difficult especially if
you're tired right yeah yeah yeah
they weren't doing it and i was like all
right no worries we'll do it we'll do it
so we were going and then right before
we were about to cross it they they
called us and they were like oh yeah
actually we'll we'll do it i think we
can do it yeah run like oh [ __ ] it's
like mission impossible
gotta get these boys back i'm trying
to start saving private ryan back to the
hotel we've got to get them back over so
we had to quickly like rush these guys
and we were like no falling just go
don't don't stop just just be good
yeah because they shut it off at 3 30
for some reason i don't know why
it's just 3 30 the sun [ __ ] sets so
you just can't see anything especially
up there like even during the day the
visibility was so bad right that's
pretty bad yeah yeah i definitely
understand why people will snow and ski
board from this trip though especially
on the last day where the visibility was
clear and i just kind of realized oh
snowboarding and skiing is just hiking
but the fun part
right because you're going down yeah go
go you got the
you get like the amazing view but you
don't have to put in the effort of like
getting that amazing view isn't it crazy
when you like you're on the ground and
you look up at the mountain and you see
us steep some of these things yeah yeah
yeah and you're like [ __ ] i i skied down
there i snowballed down there it's crazy
yeah because i remember on the first day
when we stayed on the beginner slope so
the beginner slope had this ski lift to
take us up the beginning slope and
taking us up because it was so slow it
took us like what 15 minutes i think
yeah it's like 10 10 10 10 15 minutes so
in my mind i'm like oh we're going up
like half the mountain holy [ __ ] and
then i remember on the second day when
conor was like oh yeah we're gonna go to
the top of the mountain today and i'm
like cool where was the beginner slope
and he points this point which is like a
tenth of the way up the mountain and
you're like
what
you mean you mean we were this low
but the view was so good it was already
amazing what's going on
10 out of 10 would uh recommend skiing
to uh anyone who like me as a kid one
wasn't able to go and uh especially if
you're from a southeast asian country
john is a white man now
unfortunately it just happens to be like
the most expensive vacation sport you
can do yeah but it is good it's really
good you know you can do budget ones
plenty of like budget packages that i
know that we used to do when i was like
yeah yeah japan definitely has those as
well yeah for sure
like the all-inclusive thing i need
this episode is sponsored by honey we
all shop online and we've all seen that
promo code field taunt us at the
checkout thanks to honey manually
searching for coupon codes is a thing of
the past honey is the free browser
extension that scours the internet for
promo codes and applies the best one it
finds to your cart honey sports over 30
000 online stores from games to fashion
brands even food delivery but connor how
does it work well imagine you're
shopping on one of your favorite sites
and then when you get to the checkout
you'll see the honey button drops down
on the side and then all you have to do
is click apply coupons wait for honey to
go through all of the coupons that it
knows for that website and if it works
you'll be watching the prices drop and
your savings increase recently i had to
buy a bunch of camera gear and luckily
honey saved me 20 on a big purchase
honey has found it's over 17 million
members two billion dollars worth of
savings so if you don't already have
honey you could be straight up missing
out on free savings it's literally free
and installs in a few seconds and by
getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and supporting us the boys so what
are you waiting for get honey for free
at join honey dot com slash trash taste
that's join honey dot com slash trash
taste did you guys get up to anything
else on your holidays how was your
christmas
christmas tomorrow's well it was
supposed to be uh in australia well
that's exactly why we went on the ski
trip yeah because that didn't happen
like we've been trying to plan a ski
trip for two years
and what it took to take us to finally
plan the ski trip was a global pandemic
to cancel all our plans once again
um to be like well guys i know you guys
are free this weekend yeah or i know you
guys are finally free this week let's go
on a ski trip yeah um hopefully we'll go
on another ski trip that won't take as
much time or not two years later two
years later
uh yeah my christmas news was very chill
yeah spent it with some mates uh played
a lot of martial
like i played a lot of martial i played
a lot of marginal tft
of course you did of course is that your
new apex yeah i played with daddies and
emily a bunch so i was like addicted to
it it's fun it's fun i don't know
it's like nfts but
you can leave
i've never understood tft like it's uh
it's auto chess isn't it what does that
mean i don't [ __ ] know it's hard to
explain right because like
it doesn't like the blockchain yeah it's
not the blockchain it like it's a game
that you can't easily describe
how you describe kind of like the
blockchain
maybe if god played it he's really god's
really good at giving short descriptions
to stuff i've noticed
that's why it's my job that's that's
literally what i do
i'm not when i play this game it's like
well it's kind of like ah
it's like a
battle simulation
chess thing you buy units and then you
place them and then it plays out on its
own the battle
so it's like tower defense but chess but
then every like it's one battle and then
you you lose health all don't miss
health depending on what happens yeah
but like tower defense is kind of like
that right you buy units and then it
plays away right yeah but you're playing
against another player
so you're so he's buying stuff and
you're buying stuff and you're placing
them on the board right and then you go
against each other and then you have to
you also get like stuff that comes up
and you it's a game gambling but like
there's like rerolling for like more
choices
it is a very boring game when you
explain it extremely so
right it's fun you say that about most
things it's one of those games again
like i wouldn't recommend playing it
alone there's uh
with friends it's great yeah i think
with friends it's really fun yeah
there's a lot of ways it's like chill
because it's not too intense like you
can talk like league is too intense i
feel league like i never like i've tried
playing league with mates before and i'm
just that silent guy because i'm like
concentrating too much on the gameplay
to be able to communicate with my
friends um or like have a good time it's
great there's a lot of down time in the
game yeah you're not doing anything so
you can just chat yeah it's you can do
it very casually it's really chill yeah
it's a fun game i recommend it okay i've
been i've also have been trying to game
i've been trying to get can i sound any
more boomer
but i've been trying to find a game to
get into still still kind of looking uh
i started pokemon recently the newest
pokemon uh the switch diamond first
pokemon ever right huh is it your first
pokemon game ever no it's not my first
pokemon game ever it's my first pokemon
since pokemon ruby
the original pokemon ruby holy [ __ ] on
the uh
i don't know when does pokemon get good
i've forgotten that that means you're
playing it yeah no no that means she's
not enjoying it yeah i'm i'm not really
enjoying it i'll be honest because i've
done like the first two like gyms now
for pokemon diamond and i'm just like i
remember being huh that's it oh that's
well that's to be fair that's how far i
got it's like [ __ ] ten minutes
it's like it's like two two hours two
three four hours yeah
is it really
it's i mean it's like maybe like an hour
is it there's a lot of dialogue you have
to sift through there is a lot of
dialogue a lot of like because okay
here's the thing when you go to newtown
do you talk to everyone [ __ ] no okay i
talk to everyone i'm like i'm like okay
this is he's a classic jrpg this is this
is me this is jrp
being like i have to talk to everyone
and about
i can't miss the items right about an
hour and i'm just like this is really
[ __ ] boring
but why are you talking every so often
they give me an item so i must talk to
everyone otherwise i'm not going to get
all of the items a potion yeah yeah
five five hundred of them they gave me
sometimes they give me a super potion oh
[ __ ]
it's like 500 pokemon how many potions
like not needed to change my pokemon
once since like my main pokemon yeah i
don't know like
maybe uh maybe my experience is
different from my experience as a
childhood because as a child
it was just so easy for me to immerse
myself into a game this is why pokemon
like challenges are so good and they've
got that's why people love them on
youtube like it's a way to turn a
pokemon game into a more challenging and
i suppose adult
yeah
way more fun i can't i can't play
pokemon vanilla anymore i have to make
it a challenge so fun randomizers are
fun because because i i came into this
thinking i haven't played pokemon since
pokemon ruby i can just play this
casually and have kind of the same
experience i did as i did as a kid yeah
and i don't know if i'm just not far
enough into the game yet but i mean to
me like two three hours into a game is
like
mostly most of the time that's what i
give a game before i'm just like do i
stick with this game and fully commit or
do i try another game i don't think you
like the game gun maybe maybe i don't
maybe i don't maybe you should try a
nuzlocke version of it that'd be more
fun what's the mazlock again nuzlocke is
like permadeath basically oh so if you
poke my face you die it dies quote
unquote and you have to release it and
you can only catch one pokemon in one
area there's lots of different rules
it's really good there's lots of local
rules as well you can you can kind of
mix it up with like different other
rules why wouldn't you just if your
pokemon's gonna die why wouldn't you
just like grind like crazy well i mean
some people do but the challenge but
then there's a challenge element of like
do i want to grind for 50 hours or do i
just want to like gamble and go for it a
lot of the time people aren't willing to
grind for 20 hours just to secure that
pokemon well it's more fun and on stream
it's very good it's very good
it sounds like great stream content that
just sounds stressful to me it is
stressful yeah
that looks a hell stress i saw someone
do uh one pp challenge what's that
every pokemon they're only allowed to
use the move once oh [ __ ] in like one
battle i think yeah yeah unless it heals
up again right yeah yeah there's there's
some pretty [ __ ] obscure challenges
and there's the soul link which looks
really good
basically like where you both of you do
another together and like if joey's
pokemon dies when we caught it at the
same time my pokemon dies too yeah
do you think pokemon should have a
difficulty setting i think they should
just well i don't know why they haven't
had their own nuzlocke into the [ __ ]
game just call it whatever they want to
call it they'll they'll remove their
name nozzle because it's pokemon they
won't they don't give credit to anyone
yeah uh but i don't know why they
haven't put it in the game people do it
because it's at the end of the day it's
still a children's game yeah but like
people are doing this to their games
anyway and people are going to do it why
not just add the option like it's not
that it's a children's game
people but like surely adding like the
especially like a randomizer right
surely that's easy to add oh yeah it's
helpful go in the code be like random
all and yeah it should work right super
easy i know because like for me i've
never i never got the pokemon
conversation before because i just
hadn't played a pokemon in so [ __ ]
long but now that i've now now that i've
started to play i'm just like
when does like when does this get fun
how long how long do i not need to be on
autopilot for before this is yeah it's
because
you're playing normally i think if you
tried another lock on on a stream you'd
enjoy it a lot but i i like if i'm not
supposed to play it normally as a casual
player who knows zero about pokemon gold
for that
am i too old for that connor you've
played too many games you know how to
game so i'm not even a gamer i'm not
even a gamer i'm not jrpgs right yeah i
play like grinding for like 15 hours to
like get one sash or something i don't
know you're too good
you're too good at like grinding yeah
but and pokemon now actually doesn't
require any grinding you can just do it
like you'll start a pokemon stomps when
did that happen i remember in the
original pokemon as a kid i had to like
grind the [ __ ] out like even just like
the first two
first two gym leaders
that's so [ __ ] broken yeah
what did they have that was such a like
added that in like x and y i think no it
was before that i think really black and
white wait no oh no black and white they
didn't have it i think it was x and y it
was always an item but it always only
gave it to one pokemon yeah yeah and
then now they just they were like [ __ ]
it just turn it on for everyone you get
experience by catching pokemon as well
which was never a thing yeah you get
experienced by catching when you catch a
pokemon yeah the pokemon in your party
get experience yeah yeah as if you as if
you defeated it yeah they just they just
[ __ ] they're just oprah winfrey and
[ __ ] the experience like you're
getting xp you hit exp
like
as as as a gacha gamer i'm disgusted by
the lack of grinding i need to do in
this game
like
as a gamer i'm disgusted by you
i haven't yeah i have been thinking to
do maybe like shiny runs or like uh you
know like stuff like that where it's
like a little more challenging you know
yeah
yeah
yeah the really a really fun one i did
was uh i did like a pokemon emerald mod
where when and whenever you enter a
building it teleports you to a random
part of the map oh yeah i've seen that
one that one was really fun but because
it was so [ __ ] hard because you had
to like route everything
on your own yeah so if you weren't
familiar with the map of the game you
were just [ __ ] true
that was really fun though because it's
like it gives on a completely different
challenge to it yeah it actually becomes
like really entertaining and fun
so all new pokemon games just this easy
unless you like they all artificially
add difficulty to your own run yeah okay
i'd say ever since like black and white
or x and y is where it's really starts
like hold your hand i honest i
understand gamers now
i thought you guys were being babies
complaining about this
it actually it actually holds your hand
now
especially if you've played pokemon ever
since the beginning yeah yeah i go from
that which is like if you catch a
pokemon you need to commit to leveling
it up oh dude like kids if i want to
give a kid today who grew up on like
sword and shield yeah like the new
remakes give them like the original blue
or like red and black play this game and
yeah watch them like have a mental
breakdown of how difficult it is
compared to what they get today did you
did you see the uh [ __ ] what was it
called [ __ ] um i totally forgot no sorry
oh
great
[Music]
yeah no because i remember as a kid i
don't know it's it like some things just
felt rewarding that i don't feel
rewarded with this game for example when
you level up your pokemon every pokemon
just levels up automatically yeah it's
like it's like an auto leveler
it was the pokemon let's go eevee and
pikachu oh yeah yeah yeah they gave your
starter pokemon like increased stance
the eevee or pikachu and it had a
special move yeah just one shot
everything yeah so they gave they gave
you like a starter they could just one
shot the most [ __ ] part about evie i
really enjoyed evie to be fair but like
the most [ __ ] part about evie was uh
i did an eevee only run on stream once
because it's just so [ __ ] easy but
like in in some of the pokemons you go
to there's just this dude who's like i
can teach your eevee any move of any
type for free which one would you like
it's like fire move and it's like and
they're like really [ __ ] powerful
moves as well so it's like uh
what's the catch it's like no catch
it's because you talked to me i was like
oh good and i did i think i did the
eevee only run in like four hours it was
like one of the easiest [ __ ] games
ever
i only did it because i like evie so
when it's like was it after pokemon ruby
that everything started to just get
easy the original diamond and pearl was
still like in that same difficulty range
right i think i reckon it was around
like x and y like 6th gen
where they introduced like the whole
like experience sharing and like the
really like holding your hand element
because sun and moon was just so like
ridiculously easy right same with sword
and shield as well and then everything
every other remake since then it's just
been like baby mode i remember when i
was a kid in the games this is like
boomer i remember i was back in my day
back in the morning every game was just
[ __ ] impossible [ __ ] yeah right but
now we've gone too far
i remember crying trying to beat the
first stage of mega man 2. you know i
ride a game on game boy right it was
dalmatians 101
hardest [ __ ] game ever played in my
life
did the disney games like game boy
advance was so hard not even game boy
it's like game boy oh game boy oh [ __ ]
this [ __ ] was impossible i don't even
know what the [ __ ] i was doing like this
is this is how [ __ ] games were back then
like yeah i didn't even didn't even tell
you the objective yeah you just have to
go around and figure [ __ ] out you don't
know what kills you i don't know what
the [ __ ] is going on i don't i don't
even know
i don't i don't even see cuellarville
once in that game i was just going
around this [ __ ] thing
right it was like a construction site
and i was i was one of the [ __ ] dogs
and i was like what is this [ __ ] and i
remember like accordions were killing me
like what is this game like i i just
don't understand like back then they
used to just put [ __ ] was it one of
those like unlicensed disney games no no
it was an actual life oh my god this is
back where like licensed games are just
like just uh just put a platformer and
make it impossible yeah just
yeah it was back then where it was like
take the ip put it into the mario
universe change the [ __ ] design a
little bit you have a game
so that's what the mickey mouse game was
the one that i scammed to my friend
basically it was like it was basically
just a mario platformer but it was
stupidly hard actually remember i had
this like ps1 game and it was like a
shrek game
it was like a shrek
uh
a shrek picnic game or something
right
and i'm sure shrek enthusiasts can
inform you about this game right right
remember the whole point of this game
was to like
you were assembling like i i could be
describing this completely correctly
like the parts to your picnic
yeah and you had to go and like beat
bosses and [ __ ] but like nothing worked
in the game i remembered
i have to look this up okay can we
communicate
it doesn't sound like a real game shrek
ps1 games google it right shrek i just
remember it's like a fever dream in this
game the polygons were so it's a shriek
treasure hunt that's it that's it this
game right i played this game oh my god
there was like one polygon in this whole
that looks like arsed what is
yeah it's 78 like this video game what
is it
what what what's the synopsis can you
read the synopsis
treasure hunt
uh
gameplay oh plot
as shrek is preparing a picnic
with fiona the three blind mice steal
all the picnic equipment such as foods
and drinks so shrek must go on an
adventure doing mini games to get the
items back before fiona arrives
but i remember it was like a bunch of
mini games right and these mini games
just like all broken up it didn't work
i love games with these kinds of shitty
plots because you can just imagine it
just being like fiona i have to go again
i should've been with the hair the
camera was like unusable and it kept
breaking my ps1
and then eventually it like just broke
and i was so close to the end of this
game i was distraught yeah what's the
last picnic item i couldn't believe it i
remember you have to go to like some
castle or something to fight these
[ __ ] mice or something like that and
i was just so angry that i couldn't
finish it i have to i have to find that
and play it you got to play it right
sounds amazing it's a great game it's
[ __ ] you just stream it i guess i should
maybe i'll stream it if you want me to
i want to see it
i actually have a game recommendation
though that i found okay um it is a jrpg
though all right
it is called 13 sentinels oh i've heard
of that have you heard of that yes so i
i've found this by like complete [ __ ]
accident because i'm just like trying to
look through my game library of like
games that sound interesting
and uh i just kind of downloaded it on a
whim because i'm just like anime game
brilliant yeah somehow it's not pokemon
anymore i say that but pokemon's an
anime game
but uh yeah i download it and it is got
it has got a really [ __ ] ins
interesting concept
so the story how i can best describe
this it's like if you take boca rano
and mix that with steins gates right
so the reason you have it's called 13
sentinels is because you have like
basically you have 13 main characters
right
and so the way this story unfolds is
that you're able to select
um a perspective of part of this main
character and the basis of this is uh at
some point in the future
um like [ __ ] kaiju come along and try
to [ __ ] destroy the world
and so these 13 kids have to save the
world from this kaiju attack right but i
think they fail or something um so time
travel exists right
so you're watching you're playing this
perspective this game from like 13
different perspectives and these
perspectives like jump between timelines
and universes depending on who you
choose
and you know and uh
whose perspective you're on um and you
think this would be a complete [ __ ]
mess right yeah like how can you tell a
coherent story when you can choose
between 13 different perspectives well
how how the game works is that you can
only progress to a certain amount of
point in one person's perspective before
you have to play another person's
perspective so one person's story
root is unlocked by playing a certain
part of another person's story roots
right so the way you would get you the
way you get delivered this story is like
little by little and you get to piece
together what the [ __ ] has happened
between
this entire [ __ ] timeline it's
actually like insane it's cool yeah like
i remember yeah i remember my my twitch
chat like telling me all about it be
like you'd [ __ ] love this good
ratings it does have good ratings that's
that's that's kind of that's kind of why
i like aegis rim 13 13 sentinels aegis
room oh it's an atlas game of course
that's why it's good
of course
yeah so so the gameplay is kind of like
kind of like a turn-based strategy it's
like
the the best way i can describe it like
it looks gorgeous yeah that looks cute
it looks really cute yeah it is a very
atlas game i realized because it's
basically a mix between a visual novel
but with gameplay elements to break up
the story of that visual novel switch
versions coming out in april this year
okay
but uh i i i highly recommend that
because that was just a that was that
was just something i played on the whim
because like i said i give everything
like
two hours or something try and grab me
and this one like grabbed me immediately
it has a very original storytelling
method and uh i'm about halfway through
and like they use like some of the
twists and turns i've seen in the story
are like [ __ ] insane atlas don't miss
me yeah yeah you really don't miss yeah
so except their new catherine game that
was [ __ ]
i know more about the memes of the
catherine game than actual actual people
that have played catherine
it was not that good because it's weird
because like a lot of atlas games just i
hear more about the japanese side
talking about it but like i'd hardly
ever hear anyone in the western
hemisphere talking about it unless it's
persona yeah that's basically the
western hemisphere or the western the
western world the western i don't know
why i said well i don't know why i said
hemisphere there isn't japan in the
western hemisphere
technically anywhere
depending on where you're working i kind
of realized that yeah yeah i feel like
yeah
i feel it's because like in the west
it's like very it's it's a very cool fan
base for those games you know yeah yeah
because they are like the jrpg players
jrpgs a lot of people like anime game no
thank you yeah exactly yeah they take
one yeah rightfully
yeah they take one look at the the
visuals or like the concept and they're
just like nope
i'd rather play bang bang bang
this
there's a certain kind of
expectation that comes with anime games
that in my experience is always the same
yeah you always get that same feeling
yeah even if the stories are different
the gameplay is different something
about it just always comes off as the
same in my mind i don't know why i don't
know
i don't fault people after thinking that
though that's what i like about it yeah
that's the consistency yeah i don't
fault people for thinking that though
because that's exactly how i feel with a
lot of fps games yeah where it's like
the concept is different but at the end
of the day it's still bang bang bang
yeah yeah yeah so i i don't it's fine oh
no more jrpgs for me but like even like
western driven story driven games as
well it's just like i don't know i i
guess it's the same reason why i'm into
anime versus movies and tv shows right i
mean i will always watch a movie and tv
show but those aren't the core pieces of
entertainment that i like for example
like
i remember playing the last of us and
it's a great game but i just have like
zero emotional attachment to it like
right i i play it and i can like
objectively view as a anime huh because
they're not
if they were more anime you'd be like i
care
i i don't know why it was just
it's the way western storytelling works
is that it's it's it's it's got like
different tropes and a different method
of storytelling but
i don't know why i gravitate more to
like the anime style of storytelling
because i i do think they do have a
different style oh definitely definitely
different cultures yeah different
different cultures and everything like
that and you know the way joel and ellie
were written as characters were great
they're they were great characters i
just i don't know i just didn't
emotionally attach myself to either of
those characters even though i could
tell that they were great characters why
do you emotionally attach yourself more
to anime characters then
because he's a weeb
right like what what about the way that
they do their characters is more
appealing i think it's because they're
unrealistic i i was gonna say because
that's what bothers me yeah
i i like the fact that with anime
characters there's like a clear
distinction between reality and fantasy
right and i i like having that easy
separation in my mind where you can have
great
really well-written anime characters
that are still clearly like really
[ __ ] unrealistic like just take any
[ __ ] tsundere for example yeah you
can have great written cinderellas but
at the end of the day if you meet a real
[ __ ] real life singer you're just
going to think that they're they're a
[ __ ] and
why why are they putting like why are
they doing domestic violence on their
like partner or whatever right do you
think that the authors who are like
writing these are intentionally making
unrealistic characters or they that's
like they're they're intending to do
real characters but it just comes off as
unrealistic
i think it's i think it's all based on
just like not only like the cultural
understanding and like norm of that
author but it's also the fact that a lot
of these authors are also hashing off
other japanese creations and other
japanese characters right so yes you
know that like i i don't really know of
many or any like japanese author who
takes direct influence from like western
stuff for instance yeah right like the
only one i can think of is like [ __ ]
iraqi yeah you know which is why his
characters are so [ __ ] different
compared to the traditional norm like
manga anime character character yeah not
just like visually but also like as like
a characteristic of that particular
person right yeah like why why is like
so many anime set in high school why is
that like is that a cultural thing it's
a cultural thing why why so it's because
it's for a lot of people
like high school is kind of seen as like
this basically like golden time
it's depressing
it's like for a lot of people high
school is like you know the whole thing
of like in the west of like high school
is like you know usually movies that are
based in high school in the west are
based off bad memories yeah you know
being like oh man my high school [ __ ]
sucked blah blah blah there were all
these [ __ ] people the jocks the bullies
blah blah blah right that's the norm in
the west in japan it's glorified because
to a lot of people high school was a
really fun time with like friends
they'll never get back and like yeah the
last because it's also the last years of
that person being young and free i mean
i liked high school but i wouldn't say i
liked my
yeah yeah i think as well in terms of
like a storytelling like standpoint as
well like i feel like kids in high
school or like kids going through
puberty is just already a really
interesting like character dynamic like
you can like you can get characters to
get away with a lot of [ __ ] just because
they're in puberty yeah but i feel like
there are so many [ __ ] shows and so
many anime where you look at the
characters and they could be in any
[ __ ] setting oh yeah yeah because
like some of the [ __ ] that these high
schoolers go through they like go
through like two world wars they're like
like they're like like fighting avengers
level threats when they've reached the
[ __ ] 13 years old and you're probably
not a well-written character yeah
that's clearly just an author being like
i like high school settings let's put
them into high school you know but don't
actually take full advantage of it
unfortunately but there's a lot of
authors that take full advantage of like
the high school characters and that
whole setting and actually like work it
into their characters and story mind you
that's the minority in my opinion a lot
of them are just like high school rel
realistic uh relatable with audience am
i right let's just throw them in there
you know i watched uh the gretzky the
new season oh it's good that was good
very refreshing depressing as you're
always depressing as [ __ ] yes which is
great to see because it's like one of
the only anime out there that will
actually like commentate
on adult life in japan and be realistic
about yeah
but it also says a lot when it no one
knows about it in japan yeah is that
true it is absolutely it is absolutely
unknown in japan oh [ __ ] yeah like it is
not popular at all probably because it's
too real
in japan very japanese things in it as
well it's so japanese but like yeah it's
such a good take on the japanese works
like awesome how awful it is yeah yeah
cause like i i mean it's ironic that
this has come from the same company that
you know made hello kitty yeah
just to put it into perspective like how
deep they're going so in japan right
they have a thing called say shine right
yeah which is like an employee for life
yeah you can't you can never fire this
employee they have to do something like
really [ __ ] right they have to leave
on their own right but like even the
only way they can get fired is if they
actually do something like illegal right
right
the only way they can leave that you
cannot it's like going to jail you could
literally do the shittiest job on earth
like you could like not turn up and you
cannot be fired right yeah so in japan
obviously because they decided job
security so yeah
so obviously if you told that to anyone
in any western country they'd be like i
don't think that sounds like a good idea
and because it's not because it's not
it's not like let's just be honest
obviously job security is good and you
know that's that's good but like it's a
terrible idea for any business right
like you need you need to be able to get
rid of employees yeah yeah of course but
obviously in the west we you know it's a
little uh
especially in some places they're a
little too happy to fire employees yeah
yeah yeah yeah so you know it has to be
a balance it's a balance there's a whole
arc or like story in the new season i
won't spoil who it is or what it is but
there's a character who uh because they
can't fire him uh they just relocate him
to some [ __ ] and they don't give him
any work yeah and they basically just
like morally make him want to quit yeah
yeah yeah and it's a whole thing and
it's pretty [ __ ] that's the only way
that says shane can quit yeah so they
they basically just pressure yeah they
bully you yeah
yeah so so there's a whole thing where
they like just make him [ __ ] off and
like make him you know because obviously
people are people don't want to people
want to be valued right when they do
work right and if you're just not doing
anything you're going to be like why am
i here yeah obviously if i was there i'd
be like fantastic i can catch up
fantastic let's uh let's just play apex
that's why it works in japan
i'm like are you telling me i could just
do whatever i want
and you're gonna give me the salary
what's going on
what's the latest the great school
season
all right thanks for the paycheck
this is where i'm never gonna be hired
full-time say
that i've said that
this is bad maybe that's for the better
yeah true true yeah they go to some
really dark stuff and it's a shame that
it's not being japanese i feel like it
could make waves maybe it's too real i
think it is i think it's just purely the
fact that you know a japanese person
will look at that and be like i don't
want to see this because it's just going
to remind me of a reality and uh so a
lot of japanese people that's not the
reason why they're watching there's not
really one [ __ ] dark bit i mean i'm
sure you can remember it in the new
season right can i spoil it i won't say
who it is i'll just say what happens
oh no no i know what you're talking
about yeah yeah maybe we should you
can't say this really is it that bad
it's a it's a bit of a it's a bit of a
twist all right yeah yeah yeah i've been
watching this just pretty much just
watch later season it's [ __ ] amazing
honestly your great scary is like
killing it i've i've heard mixed mixed
reviews about the fourth season actually
really some people have said that it's
just like it's
said everything it's needed to say now
and it's getting like it's like they're
trying a lot
to like bring something new on the table
first five episodes really good yeah
last first episodes boring [ __ ]
like completely unnecessary i didn't
like it that's how i felt yeah i felt
like they had a good thing going
and then they just definitely it fizzles
out at the end yeah right right but it's
still a salt season though i also
watched uh all of my sugar contents oh
i'll see you watching adam i said i said
i was going to all of it
one entrance round
and then there's a bunch of comments
that are like i hope connor doesn't
watch it because i know he's going to
hate it
did you hate it
no
wow i liked it wow okay okay that was
good honestly yeah it's really good um
i can see why people think i would hate
it yeah because the first episode i was
like
all right
we're champ
all right
i mean listen listen the way it starts
is [ __ ] weird right because you know
he gets he gets isakai does you do
because he's the first isakai right
that's all i knew about it was it was
the only thing i knew about the show is
that it was the first e6 i i feel like
whenever conor hears isa kill i like
flashbacks of like me talking like yeah
basically basically
and so you know i went into this with an
open mind i didn't read any reviews i
didn't watch any videos i didn't i don't
know anything about my shock attention
right yeah everyone knows that everyone
hypes it up yeah that's okay i'll watch
it you know
be me right first episode right i'm
watching this thing yeah and he gets
issac as a as a toddler first thing he
does is starts like admiring like the
woman's tits and i'm like
oh [ __ ]
this is the show that everyone's hyping
up
this is it
this this is it
he doesn't he didn't just admire the
tits he like makes a shrine out of like
one of their panties right yeah so the
whole first like two episodes it was
just him being like an insect
i completely forgot about that
that was the one episode of just like a
race because i was like he's like
yeah yeah yeah and i was like are we
seriously just gonna watch
a guy
another show where an in-cell just gets
rewarded with like a massive [ __ ] in the
new universe bestowed confidence uh
magical powers the most opie guy and
never has to overcome the fact that he
has really unhealthy views towards women
and sex and everything yeah but this one
was good because i felt like they he
actually at least somewhat
learned that hey maybe maybe the way i
viewed women was kind of [ __ ] up in
the past yeah and i was like
holy [ __ ]
it can be done
and they can do it not only was this the
first this guy but it was the first
self-realized insult on top of that it
was a good show and i was like i was
like this is great this is fantastic
because not only was the world building
amazing i was really i was really like
into the world i loved all the
characters you know even the parents who
they usually could have just been like
oh it's just [ __ ] parents i was
really surprised fill everything up yeah
i was really surprised when the parents
were just characters because normally
you see like anime parents are just like
half the time they're not even [ __ ]
there yeah you know and i remember
watching when they are there you can't
see their eyes yeah i remember like
watching because i'm like so used to
like isaikai speed running this [ __ ]
right where like he gets transported he
starts like getting the girl starts
beating up the dudes i don't know i'm
like five episodes into my show
contestant i'm like what the [ __ ] he's
still with the parents what the [ __ ] is
going on
what's going on and then i realized wait
a minute so i'm actually getting
invested in the the the family dynamic
and the family story and stuff like
really it's like the slow cooker
obviously guys
everything else is just like a microwave
you know can i explore one minor plot
point it's not a big deal it's really
not a big deal but she's spoiled
the moment i knew the show was built
different
really
was the
sitting there you're not watching
episode six or seven it just starts and
it's like the first thing that happens
is it's like normal family life is like
the husband has cheated on the wife with
the maid yeah and she's pregnant and i'm
like
the [ __ ] is this show doing like what
the [ __ ] is going on there was like a
whole point where he like our 10 year
old protagonist was diffusing this jerry
springer episode and i'm like i'm like
what is
was like i was like is this good this is
good right i think this is fun this is
great yeah
and then and then they actually get into
like world building later on and it's
amazing yeah i mean what i like about it
is that it does take that time to like
build up [ __ ] with like all this like
jerry springer [ __ ] just to say like hey
dad's kind of an [ __ ] as well he can
do he can do [ __ ] bad things you know
he ain't the perfect human being and
then like it helps it just like it all
plays a part into like his journey i
guess i think the biggest down point was
you finish the first season you're like
this this the story hasn't even begun
yeah i thought i missed an episode or
something when it ended i was looking
because i thought oh i'm on episode 11.
it must be 12 because it ended so bro
yeah oh yeah i was like oh where is it
it's episode 12. and then i was starting
on the new season oh saying i mean that
that i had one less episode you had a
hit on me i've only seen first season
sex scene is amazing yeah the second
season is really good second season
where is where you get so much of the
payoff
of what was like the world building
that's built up from the first season
yeah i would be quite annoyed if i
watched it and season two wasn't out
because i think yeah i felt i feel blue
yeah yeah yeah yeah but it was a great
show like again like i wanna i wanna i
can't give credit enough but the fact
that they actually like just something
different did something different and it
and it worked and the fact that this is
like the first isakai which makes me
like really concerned yeah like why did
they not take
the good parts of this [ __ ] so like what
i can't understand is how they take this
concept of like the main guy being an
insult right yeah that's what he is
right i'm gonna keep saying it i i
absolutely hate these characters as well
yeah right because what was that uh
correct technically the light novels
were like re-zero and like yeah i was
okay yeah i was i was going to correct
him afterwards so it's not the first
isekai but it's one of the most
prominent isekai's that popularized a
lot of this popularity okay okay
why
why when okay so let's say this is like
one of the first big ones right if
everyone is trying to take from this why
do they take all the worst assets
right
because each kind of me is like like i
said earlier it's just dudes who like
don't have to ever like address the fact
that they were shitty in the life before
and they just get a free do-over where
they get everything done for them yeah i
mean it's it's weird seeing like because
it was weird watching this after
watching so many isakai that have been
inspired by this show because with most
genres you have like the progenitor
right the thing that popularized a lot
of the tropes and by the time
by the time you watch that one right you
you've already seen all the tropes
before so you're like well this just
feels dated now like i'd like i don't
get why everyone hyped this thing up in
the first place because by the time you
see it everyone's already done all the
tropes differently and better yeah right
yeah but with mushokadense it's like
so many so many stories just missed the
point of why
this isakai is the way it is you know
why is it an easter egg in the first
place well it's because
he's transported to another world to
give himself another chance at life and
a lot of stories took that as just oh
let's just put this kind of fantasy
world and just disregard the fact that
he had a previous life you know that's
just
there's like there's so many subtle
things about michoacan tennessee as a
story that i feel just got
lost over time yeah in like the
different iterations of ec
that's not to say there's there's not
other sky shows that's come after it
that haven't been good but like
it's it seems like yeah they're a dime a
dozen yeah it's yeah oh yeah like the
fact that he had to sorry to go jordan
yeah it just seems like so many stories
just took the surface level elements of
this story without really thinking about
why those elements were there in the
first place this is like maybe re-zero
did this a little bit but not to the
same extent but like this is the only
other issue that i've watched i'm sure
there are others have done it where like
he actually had to like deal with the
trauma and fears that he had in his pr
past life carried over into this one
yeah because like let's say you come
into this new life right and you were
scared of snakes you're not gonna be
magically not scared of snakes
you've got the same brain right like
he's still scared of going outside i
like that they had to deal with that
yeah yeah like i love that he had to
work through all of his issues of course
i wanted the plot to go ahead and i
wanted him to like become op and like
kill everything and become the giga chad
but i also wanted to see him actually
have to work through the [ __ ] you wanted
it to be believable when it happens
right yeah and it's so much better
payoff when you get to see that yeah
absolutely because like i was also
at the point where i was like when's the
i'm enjoying this but when's the plot
gonna happen and then i've slowly come
to realize that whenever an episode is
labeled turning point i'm just like pack
like [ __ ] put your seat belts on boys
because some some [ __ ] is gonna go down
like and i've heard from like like novel
readers that they're just like oh just
wait till you get like to turning point
four or five or something i'm like
that's turning point five what what is
going on that's so good basically just a
drift course
i love shows that are confident in their
world
and like they don't need the characters
to be the world yeah it's like they they
assume the world lives independently
from the characters it's like you're
just you just we just happen to be
following some characters in this world
that's interesting we could follow any
of the characters and you still have a
great time i honestly i'll give it like
a nine out of ten so far because i i
feel i feel like like a proud father
i love it i love it
honestly it's so good like if you're
like me and you're so done with isa kai
i would give this one a shot it is
genuinely worth it when's this episode
coming out
up probably the yeah of the month right
end of the month end of the month of
february i think early first week of
february first week of february why
what's up
the first week of every year all right
yeah that's why i gave me show content
semi anime of the year
i just didn't want to spoil that
no i mean i i understand i feel like i
mean i haven't watched like odd taxi or
anything like that yet but yeah i mean i
was watching it and i'm like god damn
it's doing everything right yeah i don't
know i can't complain about anything
yeah i mean the only thing i put it
above that was arcane uh as
as the best show of this year it's been
zero days
literally arcade okay okay okay okay
movies i don't know arcade's pretty damn
good though okay arcane's pretty damn
good um but yeah i mean that's uh yeah
i'm i'm i'm i'm so [ __ ] happy i'm i'm
so [ __ ] happy about that it's it's
like when your son finally starts
getting an introduction like football
all the way down gratification feels
like oh
you're happy i like what if i came in
here guns blazing and [ __ ] can't i i
honestly thought you wouldn't like it
because why why why'd you think that
because like a lot of the characters
like i said before they are well written
characters but a lot of them are like
very tropey you know very awesome yeah
very trophy but i still think like
they're well-written characters
um but i just i just i just thought
you'd look at that and just be like not
a [ __ ] cinderella with like red hair
i mean she was annoying yeah yeah
she was probably my least favorite
character yeah out of all the characters
yeah i felt like you know it's it is
hard to look past the trope sometimes i
didn't really like the main character
much actually i didn't really like him
as well well i i kind of liked but i
understand yeah he's not i don't think
his intention was to make him likeable
yeah i actually think who's the
character i probably the character i
liked the most actually was the spur i
love the spelling the green the snake
the green hair guy
yeah yeah yeah he's sick like you said i
like the languages that they actually
spoke languages i know right that was
cool yeah that was really refreshing
yeah for once where you're like are they
speaking a foreign language because
they're always just speaking japanese
finally
because i remember when they were
speaking i'm just like when are they
gonna switch to japanese it's just like
world building man they just
make sure like
and then you know it pays off when he he
learns how to speak these languages yeah
like oh my god oh my god this is what
it's like to learn a language oh my god
it's like
a reasonable boundaries like the real
world it's like the real world holy [ __ ]
who would have [ __ ] thought
i have so much of an appreciation
appreciation for that knowing what he
went through to learn that
this is one of those
shows where i'm actually glad it's a
light novel before it's an anime or
anything because i think that it's
really going to benefit from
being in uh like a long form written
yeah so you can hash out the details so
they can really get like the world set
because you know sometimes when shows
come this big right they kind of get to
the point with like oh we gotta we gotta
get the seasons out come on people yeah
it's the hot [ __ ] come on we gotta
finish it yeah so i'm hoping that
doesn't happen i hope the anime because
i'm not gonna read the light novels
because the anime is so good and why
would i yeah i mean like the anime is so
good the production values were like
insane yeah um like some of some of the
too the jump from season one to two was
definitely noticeable i know it's there
it got better like it looked a lot
crisper yeah i mean it's just it's just
an all-around amazing production watch
watch the show watch my show
i'll definitely have to watch season two
i've been talking about it for [ __ ]
ever and i'm like so so [ __ ] funny
right now i'm i'm happy i'm happy you
know what connor maybe i'll play
i'm gonna play
maybe uh i'll play i'll play when's our
apex stream corner
how many how many hours like that dad
that's like son
i'll do something you like this time
i'll
count the exact run time of my show
that's how many hours
that seems fair all right when this
episode is i'll i'll play apex with you
there we go there we go
channel now guys and uh we've all got a
second channel that's uh we uploaded
right now
the gantt channel is going to turn on
april i uploaded every other day on that
channel and every other day you know
[ __ ] me
how did you have that much content
stream streams backlogged i have a
backlog as well on there oh okay um yes
i took all of january off
uh i didn't do any i didn't upload any
videos in january yeah well maybe one i
don't know i don't know because this is
before the end of january yeah yeah i'm
just like how are you saying this when
uh when we
are right in january
all my plans always go correctly without
any backfiring yeah yeah this might be a
uh enthusiasm yeah yeah so yeah i took a
month off it was pretty chill really
weird waking up and not thinking about
youtube videos yeah kind of just
thinking about like oh my stream later i
play some games go
gym yeah live live life yeah
have a [ __ ] life for once
yeah because i noticed that you haven't
i mean you two haven't really thought so
much about your upload schedule which
you did before
is that just
yeah yeah i just want to take a month
off and get some stuff in on in order
i've got a bunch of videos that are
really big that i need to finish yeah
yeah and i know that if i'm trying to do
them weekly it'll be a mess so i just
want to get them i've got like three big
videos in the works at the moment okay
so i'm trying to get them all done and
then hopefully gen uh february will be a
nice roll in
probably gonna do a bunch more back to
normal
do you do you feel like after you do the
big projects that you're just gonna go
back to your normal upload schedule or
are you gonna focus more on streaming
now maybe i'll miss a week here and
there and not feel too guilty about it
i'll probably try and do three a month i
think that'll be my soft target three a
month yeah i'll probably try and do once
a week but um
just above my upload schedule
actually well i feel like if i miss a
week it's not a big deal i'm like now
right on my phone i checked i checked
the other day because i was like i
haven't uploaded in like two and a half
weeks i wonder if anyone's saying
anything no no no one's commenting no of
course so clearly nobody misses me so
i'll be all right
that's exactly what i realized when i
realized oh i don't have to do an anime
of year video on the new year yeah and i
could just wait a few weeks and uh
people were just like great i'll still
watch your content who would have
thought that the only ones who care
about our timetable is us
and no one else i mean i feel like when
you do weekly it does post you a bit
more you do yeah of course but you also
i feel it also limits yourself to like
what you should actually be doing right
yeah which is why like this year for me
i'm definitely going to like slow it
down and just like really focus on like
making each video as big as possible
yeah and for everything else like you
know i got trash taste and like my
second channel and stuff like that so
yeah whatever so what is the main
challenge anymore when trash tastes this
is the main channel this is let's be
real this is where the big ideas are
going this is where it's all going we're
doing more specials this year we're
gonna [ __ ] stream every week
you're out of here first
i hope this doesn't become poorly age
things yeah i really
i'm saying it publicly so there'll be
breaks yeah of course yeah yeah yeah
but yeah i think i think for all of us
like our for this year like definitely
trash taste is like slowly becoming more
of the priority i think when it comes to
just like making cool [ __ ]
yeah because we enjoy it because we
enjoy it and uh who knew that just
having a job with your best mates uh is
fun pretty sure
god forbid have a carry every week
that's life
speaking of watching anime i know a
bunch of people who have also been
watching anime very publicly uh probably
very old news by the time this episode
gets really dumb as [ __ ] of 2022 so far
but
but somebody twice has just begun we're
already taking an l but yeah basically
at the time of recording uh pokemane has
been banned for watching avatar the last
airbender and also disguise toast has
also been banned for watching death note
i believe um on their twitch streams
yeah uh to their tens of thousands of
viewers and i i
by the time this gets released maybe
more people will be banned maybe not
i don't know but it's definitely
sparked a discussion about
copyright and dmca and i think people
online are calling it the tv matter
which uh i couldn't [ __ ] believe was
a real thing polygon wrote this article
that was like oh this guy starts he was
just testing out the tv matter and i
think my favorite comment i saw on a
quote retweet was like calling it the tv
meta is like shooting yourself in the
head and calling it the gun better
it's the dumbest argument it's crazy
like watching stuff like the uh totally
not mark right with like toei yeah just
like nuking his channel yeah for like
talking about one piece yeah for not
even breaking dmca you know and then
you know the twitch stream we should go
and watch the entirety of hunter hunter
yeah because i remember like when i
first heard about this i thought it was
i thought it was actually just like a
joke yeah i thought i thought it was
like a parody article i'm just like
where's the onion article and then i
then i log on to and then i log on to
twitch
and then i see you one of like the
biggest streamers on the pla i'm just
gonna [ __ ] i saw xqc yeah streaming
hunter hunter like innocence like a
hundred thousand people and i'm just
like i was watching because i was like
is that is there a meme like where's the
meme come and then i slowly realized oh
they weren't joking people are actually
doing this and then um conor informed me
that ludwig had already made a video
about it and i think what bothered me
was that people were like calling
like calling him out for calling other
people out for being like yeah why are
you why are you knocking on people or
something like that and i'm just like
imagine you're like broadcasting a
football match in a football stadium
that you don't own because that's what
the equivalent of it is right they're
broadcasting this to like 90 000 people
one guy's like uh is that is that
allowed and like and people are just
actually like shh don't tell people and
it's just like are you [ __ ] kidding
me there's 90 000 people watching this
right now
how can you snitch on someone when
there's 90 000 people watching this one
[ __ ] thing
so dumb and the fact that people trying
to argue it's fair use or anything it's
just so stupid
yeah the theory is ridiculous i
understand right because a lot of the
viewers who are watching this probably
enjoyed it they probably loved watching
sqc watch hunter hunter yeah of course
i'm sure everyone would love to watch us
watch jojo unfortunately we can't do
that yeah because one
we're not [ __ ] dumb we don't just
watch [ __ ] we literally
literally be breaking the law i i did a
watch along of jojo on my stream
uh but i didn't show the visuals i
didn't show audio i should have a
timestamp yeah you can go to your
netflix and we can watch along yeah it's
not as good of course it sucks because
you can't see it yeah but it gets the
law to do that yeah and also we live in
japan we probably actually throw it in
jail if we did that yeah oh yeah no you
will
um you know it's just like what what
annoyed me the most about it was again
like it was people
trying to be like it was very like
tribal in a sense they were like you
can't say my stream is bad for doing it
they were just watching you know it
doesn't do any harm so what if they get
banned it's like yeah but yeah because
that streamer already makes like five
million dollars a year of course they
don't give a [ __ ] if they get banned
yeah but like what about the guy you
know there's other smaller streamers who
maybe enjoy the the freedoms of the
current copyright system where they can
kind of you know tell the line a little
bit
safer you know not not watching stuff
but maybe i can show you a clip yeah
remember you couldn't watch youtube on
twitch before yeah you know you can now
and even then that's controversial
but
i just feel like it's selfish of like
the bigger creators who already are well
established don't have to worry about
income or anything and they can get away
with it
yeah right they'll come back you know
they'll get banned they'll come back
they don't give a [ __ ] that you know i
you know if anything them getting banned
is just more publicity to them yeah
because that's why right it's like it's
like you can get banned and you're a
headline and people are like oh my god
you're banned that's so crazy we'll come
back and like you'll get even more
viewers and you come back it's like it's
just i don't know it just seems selfish
to me it is and the the fact that
everyone's trying to call it a meta and
play a joke with it and stuff is really
frustrating when you know you know we we
work in japan right we talk a lot with
the you know with the anime companies
and try and work with them and try to
convince them that youtubers and stuff
aren't psychopaths
i think that's what like
bothered me the most yeah which is like
as someone who does make content that
really does require fair use and a
strong argument for fair use even i
think like sometimes i'm still like
touting the line sometimes with how
companies view my content right because
it's such a new concept that it's going
to take time to like convince big
companies that hey please don't strike
my stuff because it is under fair use
and
when you have when you have like [ __ ]
like this and then on the other end of
the spectrum you have people just
broadcasting licensed tv shows movies
anime whatever it's just what is what's
going to happen is that it's just going
to make it harder for the [ __ ] 60 70
year old guy looking at new content to
be like well i guess everyone's just
broadcasting my [ __ ] right well i guess
i should strike down everyone what is it
what is the thing that's going to happen
is that it's going to make it hard for
big corporations to tell the difference
between what is fair use and what isn't
because when there's people who are
abusing the system because this is an
abuse of the system then it's just gonna
be harder for the guy who was actually
trying to stay within the system to
prove that he is actually staying within
the system yeah i feel there's just so
many like youtubers on twitch streams
just content creators who are like you
know doing our best to like at least try
and like yeah as you were saying like
show the japanese corporations being
like hey you know fair use is a thing
we're not using your stuff all the time
for malicious intent we do it because we
genuinely love it we want people to know
about it yeah and but we will follow the
rules that are laid out as much as we
can but at the same time you know i
scratch your back you scratch mine you
know like kind of like forgive me
sometimes you know but now with this
whole [ __ ] tv meta [ __ ] if i feel
all that effort it's just gone back to
zero yeah especially on twitter if if
it's not speculating of course but like
obviously like it you know it could it
could really change sometimes right yeah
i mean like i mean the music industry
did it with twitch eventually they were
like oh [ __ ] uh yeah you shouldn't be
streaming music it's not good and people
are like whatever i'm testing out the
music matter you know yeah because like
the thing though the thing the other
thing that bothered me is that
you know you can't really feign
ignorance because there is a precedence
for this
youtubers have felt it for [ __ ] years
with their copyright system even twitch
streamers and i know a lot of twitch
streamers i complained a lot when they
had their dmca
controversy with the music thing that
happened right where basically every
piece of music just got claimed and you
couldn't even play some games because
some of the music was called it was
bound to happen anyway yeah which is
about youtube have been dealing with
that for years yeah like it's you know i
i don't know it's very entitled you know
and that's what it is it is entitlement
a lot of the the streamers that were
doing this yeah just like don't give a
[ __ ] because
why would they they don't mind yeah they
get the headlines they get the views
they already got paid they already have
these contracts with these companies
and they know they'll come back yeah
yeah okay because they get special
treatment yeah and then you have like
people on the other side of the fence
people like totally not mark who like if
you don't know the story behind what
happened with tony not mark i i believe
like toei strikes hundreds of his videos
over 150. over like 150 videos at once
uh some of them not even even like
having any copyrighted material on there
right some of them were just like i
believe his face or like
some of them some of those were drawings
of dragon ball characters that he yeah
yeah and so his channel basically got
completely like so many of these videos
got completely wiped away and he was
like fighting tooth and nail yeah to
like try to get in contact with toei to
be like please toei bring my videos out
of copyright jail please this is fair
use and i believe that even now it's not
been sorted no i believe now is he he
basically just like gave up yeah i
believe he just is so [ __ ]
heartbreaking because i think like a
third of his channel just disappeared
yeah exactly and that's like it's like
could you imagine that it's just like
years of work
gone yeah and that to me it's just like
well it's like there's this guy fighting
tooth and nail to try and prove that his
videos are [ __ ] fair use and his
videos do deserve to be and they are
used yeah two to two to like a company
that doesn't know the difference between
fair use not and then on the other side
of the spectrum you have other people
who are abusing the system to be like
well you know whatever the ban the
banham is coming down i think i can i
can take like a
two-day vacation a month vacation
whatever um and the people who feel the
repercussions are the people who
are like on the load end of the tier
list with
let me rephrase that no end of the
spectrum lower end of the spectrum of
twitch streamers yeah the
the smaller content creators that's
that's the [ __ ] word i was looking
for the smaller concerts are greatest
you know a lot of these the bigger
content creators you know i know or you
know i i think highly often it's kind of
sad seeing them do this and like yeah
some of them just not caring and i was
just like this is just sad
like you know i i also just think you
should to be a good example yeah like
why not just like make stuff i don't
know like because what's gonna happen is
the big streamers do it then everyone
goes oh if the big streamer is doing it
i can do it too yeah but of course they
don't realize those big streamers if
they get in trouble all they'll get is a
slap on the wrist if the smaller creator
does it they're probably [ __ ]
permabanned yeah because i'm just like
like to preface this i don't this isn't
like us trying to start drama with any
of the content creators that did this
because a lot of the content creators i
actually respect as content creators you
know yeah um it was like kind of said i
was just a bit disappointed that they
did
yeah they didn't set a better example uh
because they i like i know that
you know we're all content creators we
we know what's going on here you know
yeah we know what the repercussions are
going to be or that what they could be
so it's just
like i couldn't understand why they were
poking the hornet's nest i guess some of
them were doing it you know
intentionally trying to get banned as
well right some of them admitted that
that they wanted to be banned right
because it's good for headlines as well
yeah yeah you know if you're if you're a
bigger name and you have more websites
you know because there are websites that
are just dedicated to you know literally
just talking about twitch streamers yeah
and then like post these articles they
get them recommended to me all the time
on google oh yeah yeah of course you
won't believe what ludwig said and it'll
be like ludwig's i i like jump king so i
i hate these articles they're so [ __ ]
[Laughter]
it's a little thing called independent
journalism but it's like how have you
then you know at least take a clickbait
and not even made it somewhat
interesting
even more boring
yeah no because like i i think what the
other thing that made me like lose brain
cells when i was like scrolling on my
twitter to see what the reaction was was
the amount of people who were calling
out people who were like
basically saying hey you maybe you
shouldn't you know stream
uh or broadcast anime movies to like
your audience or whatever and anyone who
said that
was basically
basically called out to being like for
being like a corporate bootlicker or
something like that you know or just
like why are you defending the
corporations and it's just like this it
turned the argument into something
completely different because we all know
dmca is like a decade old [ __ ] law
that is outdated for how the internet
works right yeah um we're like we're
content creators we we know that there
are so many things that are broken about
the dmca system we know that but that's
a separate issue to what is going on
here you know a system can be broken and
people can also abuse the system at the
same time
they don't have to be mutually uh they
don't have to be the same thing they can
be mutually exclusive
um and just just seeing people try to
defend this just like kind of kind of
just made me [ __ ] lose it was wheels
it was really weird seeing how open
everyone was like yeah no of course it's
okay and i'm like yeah
just because you like it doesn't mean
it's okay and just because you can't be
bothered to go into google and look it
up yourself it's like like obviously it
would be sick to watch anime with 90 000
people live oh it would be safe
i would love to do that yeah we can't
we're not allowed
until until again these like ip holders
understand that it's okay and we're not
saying this shouldn't be the case you
know what i would say that if a company
wants to be [ __ ] five heads they
would allow people they would they would
allow people to stream all their old
[ __ ] forgotten shows and bring it to
a new audience i think that would be a
five-head move but until they come until
people allow it it's still illegal you
know you still you're still like you're
still putting risk that you're putting
you're still putting risk on an entire
platform that you're going to put the
clamp down for all the content creators
on that platform you know it's like that
japanese youtuber who got to react to
all of attack on titan and like oh yeah
right he like uploaded all of him yeah
he had he had this uh he had this deal
with the attack on titan ip
and he was just like oh yeah so uh you
got a second channel and it's got like a
million subs uh just put all of attack
on titan on it you're like yeah without
reacting yeah i saw that with him
reacting to it and it was completely
legal you know what's crazy to me is
that like
the whole entire youtube community
everyone everyone online hated reaction
channels yeah they came down so goddamn
hard in them and like 2015-16 yeah and
then like why is it different now i
don't understand no everyone what
happened like is it because it's live is
that the only difference like i don't
understand the twitch meta the tv the
react meta the three members the reactor
i guess
i guess what we've learned what we've
learned
what we've learned is that
it's it's it's a bad thing to do
unless your favorite content creator is
doing it then it's not yeah exactly
all right that's a good message to
entertain
yeah
i just want to go throughout like all of
history and just just start calling like
the most despicable acts of human
history just like a meta
i do the after jar all right well if you
guys uh hey do you guys want to join the
patreon medal look at all these patreons
they're limit testing the patreon meta
right now guys if you want to join them
then uh maybe go to our page on
patreon.com also follow us on twitter
send us emails on the subreddit and if
you had our face listen to us on spotify
but uh yeah god tv meta is now my least
favorite phrase of 2020 nft tv meta yeah
what about the nft tv what about the nft
matter we're just going through the
blockchain meta right now
gross all right anyway you've uh you've
been watching trash taste this has been
the trash taste better uh
join the patreon matter that's the
number yeah the patreon manager yeah
that's the only good matter and we'll
see you all next week bye
[Music]
you